welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast in today's episode I formally
announced that I am in fact a completely
different person than Eric Helms and
Greg share some impressive feats of
strength after that I've got a research
review segment about how antioxidants
relate to nitric oxide and hypertrophy
and Greg tells us all about his new
stronger by science article about the
concept of effective reps finally we
interview Lauren cleanse assemble who
tells us about her research on muscle
fiber types a recent study on training
volume for resistance trained females
and much more as always thank you for
listening and we hope you enjoy welcome
back to the stronger by science podcast
this is your one and only hosts Eric
Trexler and today I'm joined by my
temporary guest host Greg knuckles
before we get into the real meat of the
episode today I do want to come clean
about something
so there's kind of an ongoing I don't
know how I'd put it there's I would call
it an assault I was gonna go toward
there's some ambiguity out there that I
feel like maybe I've been partially
contributing to well I mean just given
the utterly depraved nature of the
accusation here I mean I would call it a
pretty major assault personally let's
just let's just get straight to it here
so today we're recording on a Thursday
which means an episode went live this
morning and like two of the first four
comments were to congratulate Eric Helms
on a job well done and so I want to
clear the air and I want to put the
rumor to bed Eric Trexler who is I
and Eric Helms those are two completely
separate human beings so it if you
thought Eric Trexler was a pseudonym or
like an alter-ego that Eric Helms
developed that's not accurate
Eric Trexler is not some kind of shell
corporate entity that Eric Helms created
for liability purposes it's not like a
Marshall Mathers Slim Shady type
relationship no these are these are two
he
beings just normal human beings more or
less that are separate so different
families different genes different
heights we happen to live on separate
continents and so it seems like every
episode there's a a non-negligible
amount of people who think that after
about 40 hours worth of podcasting here
they still think Eric Helms is the host
of the show
so I've considered a few possibilities
one would be that this is an elaborate
troll operation in which case I lost if
you were trolling and that's the point
of this you win I have been trolled hard
but I think this is probably a Russia
funded operation against in connection
with gucchy fir 2.0 probably so it could
be a troll operation in which case it is
an extremely dedicated troll operation
because it's been going on for about 17
weeks that's that's a hell of a job it's
like gamergate all over again it is now
the other option is what one of the
other possibilities is that this is a
conspiracy theory that Eric Drexler and
Eric Helms are actually in fact the same
person now there are pictures of both of
us in the same room at the same time and
we also did release an episode that was
like 90 minutes of the three of us
talking and there were definitely three
distinct voices you can run that through
some kind of software to identify there
were three separate human voices on that
recording but I will say this most of
the pictures of me with Eric Helms did
they were taken in Finland and a lot of
people don't believe Finland exists and
one one thing to note just for the
conspiracy theorists out there much like
the Beatles conspiracy that Paul
McCartney is dead if you take the intro
music to our podcast press it on the
final which is the only correct way to
listen to the podcast on vinyl
of course press it on the vinyl and play
it backwards the intro music does
actually say Eric Helms is dead so so I
that was completely unintentional our
sound engineer I think just put that in
to play a joke on us but I can
understand if that is where the
conspiracy came from yeah so the thing
that kills me is we've got like a good
90 minute interview with Helms on our
show I did like a good 90 minutes on
their podcast Helms and I are both
listed as reviewers on mass every month
so it should be pretty clear like
whether you consume his stuff or my
stuff or both of our stuff that we are
in fact two separate entities you would
think right I would hope so
okay now there is a third option that
this is a deliberate misinformation
campaign by Omar in Helms again in
conjunction with the Russians in
conjunction with the Russians or the
Dutch or both so maybe they're behind
this I don't know then the fourth option
is that I'm simply too low-key and I
need to talk myself up more on the
podcast and I guess probably in the
third person I think I'd be the only way
to really get the name recognition
across when he said sure so that's the
only real actionable possibility when
you look at them the rest are kind of
out of our hands so expect over the next
several years a whole lot more of me
talking about me in a very favorable way
okay so for today's episode we got a lot
going on we do have an interview with
Lauren Collins Oh simple and we recorded
this interview I don't when did we
record that two or three months ago two
or three months ago at minimum and
things have changed a lot in the last
few months it's stronger by science in
the last few months we've made some big
changes to our coaching program which we
don't talk about much on the show but
the first thing we did a while back was
we added Greg shilts and he's our
registered dietician on staff he's also
close personal friend of ours and just
to be clear me and Greg Schulz are are
also two different people to keep up
with
this general audio universe you do need
to keep to Eric's separate and to Greg's
separate but that should be pretty
doable
yeah so completely separate Greg Schultz
who is our our registered dietitian and
we brought him on and then essentially
all of our coaching positions filled up
immediately and so like we just
completely filled up everyone's rosters
and we figured okay it's probably time
to grow again and so in the last few
weeks we added three new coaches so we
added Jason Yuri who is a doctor of
physical therapy which is cool because
that's a skill set we did not previously
have on the team we added dale keith he
was the lead research assistant in my
dissertation research and the lead
research assistant in Greg's thesis
research so we we both know him
extremely well and have been very much
in the trenches with Dale and he's a
very good guy very good coach he's been
training people for a while and then
finally the reason I bring all this up
our interview today is with the other
coach we recently brought on and that is
Lauren Cole Enzo simple now Lauren's if
you look at like the coaching tree to
borrow a metaphor that she comes from
the the lineage of people she studied
under it's insane so she started out
interning and kind of volunteering in
Brad Schoenfeld lab then she did her
master's in Bill Campbell's lab at USF
and then she went and did an internship
with Andy Galpin and while she was doing
that internship with Galton she spent a
weekend at the glute lab over with Brett
Contreras to you know hang out and learn
some stuff now she's doing her PhD under
Stu Phillips if you were into
hypertrophy and sport nutrition I don't
know if you could select a better group
of people to learn under like if you
listed like the top eight there's no way
that all five of them don't show up in
there yeah so she knows her stuff just
the fact that you would bother to go
learn from those people kind of tells
you everything you need to know like
this person at least knows where to get
stuff knows where to find information so
we interviewed a long
for we ever intended to bring her on as
a coach honestly because we wanted to
hear about her study on training volume
in female resistance trained lifters so
if you stay tuned you're gonna hear that
interview at the end of the show but
before we get to that as always we got
to talk about feats of strength yes sir
so boss of bosses 6 was pretty recent
that's a I believe it's an
invitation-only meet where a lot of the
best lifters go compete every year it's
it's basically the World Championships
for untested lifting I mean it's the IPL
world's is also pretty big but I would
say boss of bosses if anything is is a
bigger meet at this point than then i PL
worlds is not not in terms of like total
number of lifters but in terms of like
the number of records that are set and
so there were several absolutely insane
performances out of that meet one thing
that is probably worth touching on is
there were quite a few complaints about
judging at that meet several squats on
video at least looked high and to this
point I haven't seen any side videos so
I didn't see anything I didn't see
anything as egregious as some of like
the circa 2013 multiply world record
squats but there were definitely some
that to my eye from the front angles
that were available did look highly
questionable but I mean the judges
called him good I haven't seen a side
angle that's as far as I'm going to go
as far as like that controversy goes but
the judging did seem somewhat if he but
that being said Yuri Belkin who is the
god of the middle weight untested men at
this point he competed at 220 or in the
hundred kilo class he has done several
of his recent meets in the 242
or 110 kilo class and that's mostly
because he does the thing that Russian
lifters do where they just don't cut in
a very easy amount of weight to cut so
this is something that like balaiah
did back and back in the day as well
when he was taking 220 records that very
easily could have been 198 records but
at his last few meats like Erie belkin's
been weighing in anywhere between like
224 and 228 but competing at 242 instead
of cutting those like 4 to 8 pounds but
he did cut to 224 this meat squatted 416
kilos which is 917 pounds and totaled
1066 kilos which is 20 350 pounds both
of those all-time world records in the
class that put him I can't remember if
he was in first place or second place
for all time Wilkes for male lifters but
if he wasn't in first before he is now
that was a 649 Wilkes which is just
absolutely stupid that's a so he also
holds the record at 110 or 242 and the
record he just set at 220 is higher than
his 242 record which he just said back
in April which again was set at a body
weight of like 228 but he I mean he
shows no signs of slowing down he is the
god of those weight classes the second
or the next closest person at 220 is
also a very very good lifter Tom Martin
but his best total is 1085 or in pounds
2171 so there's like a 180 pound gap
between URI and the rest of the class at
this point he was one of the ones where
the squat was kind of iffy but whatever
like the lifts counted huge record for
him
also from the meet from that same mean
I'm pretty sure Christi Hawkins now
holds all four all-time world records in
her weight class she competes untested
in the 75 kilo class or 165 pound class
in kilo she went to 85 150 255 for a
total of six ninety or
pounds that's 628 331 562 for a 1521
total which I mean regardless of like
knee wraps or drug testing or anything
else like those are sick numbers at 165
for anyone and for a 165-pound female
that's also insane very similar to Yuri
Belkin she's miles ahead of anyone in
her class right now that puts her a
hundred and forty pounds ahead of the
number two total in her weight class and
like I said that's the all-time records
for four lifts simultaneously I don't
know I don't know if anyone has
simultaneously held all four records in
one weight class
since maybe Lamar Gant
I think Edie cone may have at 198 but I
I'm not sure I don't think he ever held
the bench record so that's I mean that's
an incredibly impressive feat at the
same meet Cece Ingram who is kind of the
the boss at 181 or the 82 and a half
kilo class for untested woman she
improved her all-time world record total
to the surprise of no one because she's
a beast she totaled seven thirty seven
point five or 16 26 at 181 which again
is crazy on the tested side of things
Amanda Lawrence recently posted a PR
deadlift gym lift so us APL nationals
are coming up
Amanda Lawrence I believe currently has
the world record in that weight class
which is the 84 kilo class or 185 pound
class I believe she currently has the
world record at 252 and a half kilos or
557 pounds so that that gives her a gym
lift that's about 20 pounds over her
current world record looked like she
still had some in the tank and the
probably the most important thing is in
in the video she posted grip looked very
comfortable she held it for set for
several seconds at lockout
the past I believe she has been good for
heavier deadlifts but has pretty
consistently had grip issues so it seems
like she's sorted that out and is
probably going to improve on her
world-record deadlift and the 84 kilo
class for the women is going to be a
really really fun class to watch at
Nationals this year because Amanda
Lauren's and Daniela Melo are both in
that weight class they're both young I
think Amanda's 22 and Danielle owes like
20 they're still both improving very
rapidly and they're currently tied for
the world record total in that weight
class and Amanda edges Daniela out
slightly because at meet where they both
set the world record
Amanda weight and slightly lighter but
they're like super super neck-and-neck
Daniela hasn't been posting to Instagram
as much recently but I'm sure she's
stronger as well and that's gonna be a
dogfight at Nationals that I'm very
excited to watch and then the final one
for the day actually no two more so new
all-time world record in the sixty seven
and a half kilo or 148 pound class for
untested men mikey Estrela totaled 738
kilos or sixteen hundred and twenty
seven pounds which at one forty eight
that's that's nasty so that puts him I
think that puts him close to 25 kilos
ahead of the second place total in that
weight class and one thing to note as
well is mikey Estrela until very
recently competed tested he'd totalled
like fourteen hundred and twenty pounds
or so tested at one forty eight and now
he's put close to 200 pounds on that
since he's gone untested just in the
past like year or so so he pretty
quickly took the untested total record
so it's going to be exciting to see if
he just you know absolutely buries the
rest of that class in the next year or
if he can even stay in the 148th class
but anyway very very impressive
lift for him and then the last one and I
think this was probably the most
controversial recent lift julius Maddux
as we predicted on this very podcast
took the all-time super heavyweight
bench press record previously held by
Kirill Saratov at 335 kilos or 738
pounds
julius Maddux chipped him beat him by
half a kilo benched 335 and a half or
seven thirty nine point seven pounds the
reason why this lift was controversial
is the the video that's been circulating
around has kind of become like the
superior tape for powerlifting this is a
brooder tape is like the only good video
of the JFK assassination and like people
are people try to piece together what
happened from like this one grainy not
all that great video it's similar with
with the video of this world record
because basically what happened is he
pressed the weight the press didn't look
that hard but I think that's just how
julius Maddux pinches like it either
looks pretty quick or just doesn't go up
but it looked like he got the lift
cleanly and then he just like dropped
the bar on himself but he did get the
rack command from the ref and so like as
soon as you get the rack command it's
good like that's the end of the lift
whether or not the bar gets racked yeah
it's just such an ugly video anytime
something like that happens you're just
like it's like a train wreck
yeah I mean when you see the barred and
drop like that you're like oh yeah and
and so the reason this has become like
the Sapru der tape is it looks like when
he locks it out so he has a 5-spot
there's a back spotter and there's two
side spotters and what looks like
happens is as soon as he locks it out
one of the side spotters throws one of
his arms up like to start celebrating
and it looks like his other arm bumps
the weight and so that would like bump
one end up the other end of the bar did
like dip at that moment and that's when
it started going down but you can't tell
for sure from the video if the guy's arm
did actually hit
the weight and so like if it did that I
mean if you're holding 740 pounds over
your face and someone nudges it that
seems like a perfectly reasonable reason
for it to kind of collapse so like if
that happened I feel like that cleans up
a lot of the controversy like the video
still doesn't look any prettier but like
at that point it's not on Julius but if
the guy didn't touch it and it was that
he you know locked it out but then just
couldn't support it until like you know
the fraction of a second before he got
the rack command then it is a lot if
here but I mean you know he was benching
barely over seven like a year ago so I'm
I feel like he's gonna improve on this
record again the next time he breaks it
he's probably gonna do it more cleanly
but yeah so that was the most
controversial recent lift but I mean it
passed it's on the record books
Julius Maddox is the new king of the
benchpress yeah and he like you said it
went up quick mm-hmm it seems very
unlikely that he would just absolutely
manhandle that weight and then at the
very top be like nope too much yeah you
know I mean and in like you said I think
he's gonna beat that in a matter of
months anyway
yeah I'm in the camp of I think the
spotter touched the bar but the the
controversy is like you can't tell that
for sure right you know yeah but yeah so
that is that's it for feats of strength
moving on to the next segment this is
the research review segment of the show
and eric is going to do a research
review regarding antioxidants and muscle
hypertrophy so I think probably a lot of
people are aware of some of the
literature looking at say high dose
vitamin C or vitamin E supplementation
and the fact that that may decrease
hypertrophy or signaling associated with
hypertrophy but this actually seems to
be a somewhat more nuanced subject an
area of the research and Eric is here
with the goods
yeah so this is gonna be a fairly brief
research review segment because it's not
fully baked yet and I think I might end
up writing an article on this topic
because the more I look into it the more
I'm like ooh there's there are some
details here that require explanation
and some deep thought but what got me on
this is there was a paper a review paper
that got published last month about
antioxidants and hypertrophy and
unfortunately I couldn't access the
stinkin paper so I need to email
somebody and try to figure it out how to
get that paper but just seeing the title
I was like maybe I'll do a little search
of my own so I start looking into you
know one of the things I was interested
in is what is the proposed mechanism by
which these high dose antioxidants might
might be interfering with hypertrophy
following resistance training and I
started looking at some papers and one
thing that jumped out to me was in a
paper by IDO a tall in 2013 that's I tio
and what they were suggesting is that
the mechanism pertains to peroxy nitrite
and if you're me and you did a
dissertation on nitric oxide that is the
term that has some significance for you
it's so basically what they what they
suggested was that peroxy nitrite
activates something called the transient
receptor potential cation channel
subfamily v number one and obviously we
all know what that is I mean that's kind
of become a cliche in fitness I'm
kidding I'd never heard of that in my
entire life but yeah so basically a fun
fact about that particular receptor is
that it's also referred to as the
capsaicin receptor so am I suggesting
that red pepper red pepper and chili
pepper will make you enormous I am yeah
one weird trick capsaicin
so Eric Helms our nemesis along with the
country of the Netherlands yep
he reviewed a paper for mass I think
over two
years ago at this point it was one of
her earlier issues about capsaicin and
how it could improve if memory serves on
that paper it was looking at repeated
sprint performance but it seemed to have
fairly notable effects there and the the
thing about the thing about capsaicin
that a lot of people don't realize is
that like you eat it it it's hot in your
mouth I think people realize that yeah
oh come on come on Eric I'm getting to
the part people don't realize but like
Eric noted there is this receptor that
is sometimes called the capsaicin
receptor and that's kind of everywhere
in your body and so when you eat hot
foods it not only makes your mouth burn
it also has systemic effects and you
probably experience some of those like
you feel like your body temperature is
going up you start sweating I think a
lot of people assume that that is just
in response to your mouth burning but
that's actually due to the fact that
capsaicin does have systemic effects if
you put capsaicin in a capsule and so
you know it never burns your mouth in
the first place it will still have a lot
of those same effects because it it has
impacts on I won't go so far as to say
most because I don't know if that's true
but a lot of tissues of your body beyond
just your mouth yeah capsaicin is
something that I I'm gonna pencil in
some time to do a deep dive on capsaicin
because you look at it and you see it
it's implicated when it comes to
thermogenesis performance as you
mentioned satiety satiety was the one I
was gonna mention as well and now
potentially some mechanism pertain
pertaining to hypertrophy it's just a
really fascinating thing capsaicin so I
want to look into it more and see how
much of this is interesting how much is
useful because it's not always the same
thing but in any case that this paper
was indicating that that from a proposed
mechanism was that peroxy nitrite
activates this particular receptor
which causes an activation of the mTOR
pathway and the idea was that high dose
antioxidants reduce the formation of
peroxy nitrite and that that might be
this the mechanism relating to this
apparent interference and I mentioned
you know I've done some work with nitric
oxide and that's why proxy nitrite
jumped out to me if you look at the
metabolic fates of nitric oxide a lot of
people know nitric oxide you create it
and it disappears almost immediately
it's half-life in the blood the
estimates vary because it's so small but
you you're it's rare to see an estimate
of more than a second or two in terms of
like the half-life of nitric oxide the
question is where does it go and the
answer is it could go a lot of places
but one of the metabolic fates is it is
turned into peroxy nitrite however that
conversion is drastically reduced in the
presence of antioxidants and so the
thing that's tricky is there's there's a
little give and take here so
antioxidants shuttle nitric oxide toward
other metabolic fates that in the short
term would be more favorable yours they
essentially help recycle the nitric
oxide into various different pathways
that are acutely more favorable in terms
of sustaining nitric oxide activity and
theoretically enhancing performance but
it would appear that you know from our
current understanding if you blunt that
peroxide peroxy nitrite production
effectively enough that might interfere
with hypertrophy potentially and so this
is really interesting because we have
known for some time that there is some
link between nitric oxide and
hypertrophy there have been some rodent
studies specifically that have shown if
we give these really potent drugs that
increase nitric oxide you know if we
pharmacologically really ramp up nitric
oxide production it seems to be quite
good for hypertrophy if we totally blunt
its protect its production it seems to
be quite quite bad for hypertrophy so
it's one
more wrinkled that kind of enhances our
understanding of the relationship
between antioxidants and hypertrophy but
also between nitric oxide and
hypertrophy potentially now the solution
here is kind of up in the air but I
think the I I think the solution is to
look for some kind of a middle ground so
if we could have enough antioxidants
that we are helping support nitric oxide
production and function during the bout
in a way that would generally be
advantageous for acute performance
purposes but not have such a big dose of
antioxidants that we totally blunt this
proxy nitrate formation that seems to me
like it might be a very nice middle
ground where we can still enhance
performance acutely without interfering
with training adaptations because one
without the other is there they're very
different applications of why you might
use a nitric oxide supplement or why you
might use an antioxidant supplement now
there is one study a longitudinal study
looking at a nitric oxide donor
supplement and it actually was paired
with an antioxidant because people have
known for quite some time that
antioxidants do promote the bio activity
in the production of nitric oxide and
and help to maintain its its bio
activity when it is produced so there's
a study by long at all in 2018 out of
Daren Willoughby's lab they were looking
at a product that was 200 milligrams of
reduced glutathione which is an anti
oxidant combined with 2 grams a day of
l-citrulline now there are all sorts of
caveats when interpreting this study
it's an it's a nice study it's a
thorough one it's it's one that I've
read several times big sample size they
had a nice training program like they
did things well here now a couple of the
issues it's a very low dose of
citrulline compared to the rest of the
citrulline literature usually a
citrulline dose you're
thinking that's going to be somewhere in
the 3 to 6 gram range of the actual
citrulline contribution so two's a bit
low but I think what they were thinking
is they were studying a premade
formulation so I mean it's not like they
had wiggle room there but I think also
the concept is that when you pair it
with the antioxidant you can get away
with a lower dose of the nitric oxide
precursor now the other thing is the
antioxidant in the mix was glutathione
and the evidence is a little bit mixed
in the literature about exactly how much
oral bioavailability there is with
glutathione there are some papers
suggesting it might be alright
others suggesting it's pretty poor one
of the big caveats though is the whole
point of the study was to figure out if
we give an antioxidant with a nitric
oxide donor or a nitric oxide precursor
is it gonna help with muscle growth and
probably the biggest caveat is nobody
grew like you look at a training program
the training program should have been a
very sufficient stimulus for the
accretion of lean mass it's four days a
week upper lower split plenty of volume
it should have been enough to do the
trick and sometimes the way it goes in
research is it just wasn't so after
accounting for changes in total body
water the placebo group increased lean
mass by negative point eight kilos the
citrulline malate is three groups in it
one taken just a low dose of citrulline
malate they increased by 0.1 kilos and
then the citrulline with glutathione
increased by 0.1 kilos so you know I
guarantee when they are planning the
study they were thinking okay placebo
group stays the same theoretically we
should see big or I'm sorry placebo
group will grow because it's training
right but then we'll see whether or not
the glutathione and citrulline are
having additive effects and it would
have been really cool if the placebo
group grew
the citrulline group grew a little more
but then the citrulline with glutathione
group really grew because the
glutathione was helping nitric oxide
essentially do its thing or if you know
the placebo group grew the citrulline
malate group grew more and the
glutathione in citrulline group grew the
same as the placebo thus indicating that
the presence of the antioxidant may have
blunted the response yeah that way in
any sort of interaction between the
supplements would have been neat yeah so
I I'm yeah when I say what would have
been cool that's certainly what the
sponsor of the study would have hope
yeah yeah yeah yeah because their whole
thing is they think that this inclusion
of antioxidants is is a a novel thing to
promote the effect of citrulline but
yeah any of those outcomes would have
been quite fast and it's weird that they
went with glutathione though because
like if memory serves the reason that
people take alpha lipoic acid is because
it increases endogenous glutathione
production and I think it does have
pretty decent oral bioavailability so
like if these people are making a
supplement professionally and putting it
on the market you would think that they
would go with the thing that was
actually tested versus the thing that
may not actually get into your blood in
the first place yeah it's true I don't
know what to tell you man fair enough
it's a good point now the question is
what do we do about this because like we
have that one study that theoretically
could have shed a lot of light on it but
it's just nobody grew stuff happens
I still think it's generally a good idea
as I always say to the default should be
a relatively high nitrate diet just
because of the numerous benefits of the
fruits and vegetables that tend to be
high in nitrate like you're never gonna
regret the fact that you ate plenty of
spinach and celery and berries and stuff
like it you're gonna be alright if you
want to go the nitric oxide route I've
got an article on the website about
nitric oxide that goes to all the ins
and outs of how it affects performance
and maybe hypertrophy
think you can at least say it doesn't
seem problematic when the nitric oxide
is paired with naturally occurring
antioxidants in that food matrix so like
interventions with watermelon juice as
citrulline seem to be fine
there are even some longitudinal
interventions with beetroot juice where
there are obviously our antioxidant
compounds in the juice naturally where
it does not seem to impair any of the
training adaptations over for weeks the
studies I'm thinking of we're looking at
interval like sprint training but it did
not seem to impair muscular training
adaptations at that level
I do think tentatively until we figure
out more I think it does make sense to
avoid super high dose antioxidant
supplements if the purpose of the
training is to induce adaptations which
it almost always is now for acute
performance instances that might be a
little bit different but but when we're
talking day to day training I don't it
doesn't seem like a super awesome idea
currently to go with a really really
high dose antioxidant supplements Erica
I have just a general question for you
okay have you seen any literature
comparing I guess like different kinds
of antioxidants so one of the things
I've heard which I don't know if this is
true at all or not is that the effects
on training adaptations are different if
you're talking like taking high doses of
exogenous vitamin C or vitamin E versus
if like your body's endogenous
antioxidant system ramps up so you know
one of the adaptations to aerobic
training and pretty sure is you get an
increase in like endogenous production
of glutathione and other endogenous
antioxidants so like are you aware of
any research on that or is that just is
that maybe just an idea that people have
put forth
that isn't really research like I
honestly have no idea about that if I
were to wildly speculate
I would definitely imagine there's a
pretty pronounced distinction between
endogenous versus exitus antioxidant
capacity in the sense that I wanted I I
think it'd be very easy to exogenously
just kind of flood the body with a lot
of with a high dose of compounds with
high antioxidant capacity that would
exceed the adaptation you would
experience of the endogenous system if
that makes sense I think you could
acutely manipulate the system to a much
greater degree mmm-hmm with the
exogenous so I would speculate that that
might be what's going on
I think one of the interesting questions
would be if you look at the types of
antioxidants that exist there are
numerous so to say antioxidants like
people who actually study that stuff are
like what are you kidding me like there
are so many different compounds that
fall under that umbrella of you know a
quote-unquote antioxidant one thing that
I would be interested in is looking at
these very different exogenously
do certain ones impair adaptations and
do other ones not impair and I don't
know I would imagine that so when you
look at antioxidant load there are
different assays to quantify the overall
antioxidant potential of a particular
food or ingredient or compound and so
there's a really good paper by Carlson
at all that was published in 2012 it has
the antioxidant content or the
antioxidant capacity of over 3100 foods
and supplements chills is Christ so for
all of them they said per 100 grams
based on the assay that we think is most
appropriate what is their ability to
scavenge
active oxygen and reactive nitrogen
species generally speaking so it's a
really good resource that particular
paper and I think one of the things that
I'd be interested in is aside from just
total antioxidant capacity do different
types of antioxidants have different
effects because they are very different
compounds and are categorized
accordingly so I think we still have a
tremendous amount to learn about how
antioxidants affect I think we have a
good idea of their acute effects but I
think we we have a lot to learn about
their chronic effects in the context of
a training program and how they might
interfere with training adaptations and
I think it's gonna come down to the the
dose and by that I mean the overall
capacity to scavenge and it's also going
to come down to I think it's worth
looking at all these different types and
how they might have potentially
differential or even synergistic effects
possibly but in the meantime I think at
the very least we know that there are
certain antioxidants that in very high
exhaustion is doses they do seem to
inhibit some adaptations for training I
think we certainly know that they do
increase the bio activity of nitric
oxide but if that's at the expense of
limiting training adaptations that
doesn't seem like a good a good
trade-off if we're talking day to day
training applications yes so like if
anything it could be the inverse
creatine we've talked about this before
on the podcast how folks kind of use
creatine as like a model supplement and
aren't aware of all of its mechanisms of
action such that you know we see
creatine acutely in improves performance
like reps to failure type stuff like
single session volume capacity and
people assume that well we know that
that occurs we see the creatine helps
improve training adaptations therefore
you know its ability to help you do more
work is what's driving those things you
got a really really good article about
creatine for stronger by science where
you also look through some of the other
things that creatine does and other
pathways by which it promotes
hypertrophy beyond just acutely
improving work capacity and so it would
be interesting if nitric oxide is the
exact opposite where you know maybe if
you if you do something to boost nitric
oxide signaling via you know adding
antioxidants it acutely improves
performance but has negative effects on
adaptations and this is where the the
picture gets even more complicated
though is because in the absence of
those nitric oxide or in the absence of
a high dose antioxidant if you introduce
a ton of nitric oxide theoretically that
could also increase the production of
peroxy nitrite yeah yeah and so so then
it's like well what is the balance of
increasing the nitric oxide for acute
performance benefit potentially even in
to some extent increasing peroxy nitrite
maybe but generally speaking if you look
at the literature peroxy nitrite is a
bad word mm-hmm you did like you you
don't want runaway production of peroxy
nitrite that's not something anyone
would shoot for when it comes to the
general what why is that peroxy nitride
is associated with damaging both
proteins and potentially DNA and RNA in
the cell generally not what you want so
if I want to leave humanity behind as it
were how much per oxynitride should I
should I aim for you know I I don't
think I can give you a specific dose
more research is needed but yeah so
probably not excit proxy not that's what
I mean that's one of the reasons why
people I think it's one contributing
thing of why people say Oh antioxidants
are great yeah yeah it gets rid of all
the bad stuff right like antioxidants
people treat it like this anti-aging
miracle because it scavenges a lot of
these different things or reduces their
production that are associated with
damaging proteins and damaging DNA
linus pauling was incredibly influential
he was but so so that the interesting
thing is how what's the balance where we
have enough nitric oxide to acutely
promote performance enough antioxidants
to increase its bio activity without
blunting the peroxy nitrite which
appears to be promoting some of these
training adaptations including
hypertrophy basically it's a mess it's a
very complicated inter woven web of
factors and the thing that I found most
interesting about it was I was reading a
paper purely about antioxidants and I
was like this has huge implications for
nitric oxide as well so that's why I
said it's kind of a I wouldn't say a
half-baked idea for the research review
but it's not fully baked because there's
something there when it comes to the
balance between nitric oxide precursors
and the appropriate dose of antioxidant
either in that particular combination or
in the diet overall I think for now it
seems safe to conclude that super high
dose antioxidants are not great for
training adaptations including a
hypertrophy proxy nitrite may be a
particularly influential part of that
but in terms of the exact titration
there of antioxidants in the diet
I just don't know yet but certainly I
would not advise that anybody avoid
getting dietary sources of of
antioxidants in you know moderate to
high amounts so eating a generally
nutritious diet still seems like the way
to go but I mean it kind of loops back
to what we said about these how my view
of nutrition has gone from very
mechanistic to ultimately defaulting
toward good eating patterns mm-hmm and
it's like the mechanism is like you
mentioned Linus Pauling some of these
antioxidants and vitamins seem really
nice what if we took in like completely
insane amounts of each like well it
doesn't work out as well as we thought
and so I feel the same way
this particular instance of antioxidant
should we just jam them in with training
it'll help with the acute recovery it'll
acutely increase the bio activity of
nitric oxide well it turns out once
again we kind of whiffed it does seem to
to some extent blunt training
adaptations including hypertrophy mm-hmm
so eat your vegetables train hard that's
all I got
sounds good all right so I guess it was
a few days ago now the website stronger
by science an article went up by our
very own Gregg knuckles the article was
called the evidence is lacking for
effective reps and as we've done on the
show previously one of the cool things
about the podcast is that after we
publish an article on the site we have
an opportunity to see what the feedback
is like and podcast gives us a great
opportunity to clarify things discuss
kind of how people receive the article
any questions that came up from from
readers so we do want to take some time
to talk about this article so before we
get into that Greg can you explain what
the general concept of effective reps is
yeah so the the nugget of the idea
behind effective reps is basically for
for a rep of an exercise to promote
hypertrophy it needs to be close enough
to failure that it's kind of hard and
and the reason for that is basically a
lot of the mechanistic work looking at
what kicks off muscle protein synthesis
and hypertrophy shows that like you need
it shows that one your highest threshold
motor units are probably the ones that
are the most susceptible to hypertrophy
and so they're not going to be recruited
unless a load is adequately heavy or
until you're close enough to failure so
an implication of Hinnom incise
principle which is just like a very
foundational aspect of muscle physiology
is that
loads increase more and more motor units
are recruited and then also with lighter
loads if you take them to failure for
the first few reps most of just like
lower threshold motor units will be
recruited and then as they start
fatiguing and you get closer and closer
to failure more and more of your high
threshold motor units will eventually be
recruited so you know either doing reps
with heavy weight or doing lighter
weight all the way to failure both of
those things will eventually recruit all
of your motor units so the idea being
that until you get pretty close to
failure you probably haven't really
tapped into those highest threshold
motor units and then the other thing is
most of the at least best characterized
physiological pathways that initiate
muscle protein synthesis and hypertrophy
are related to muscular tension in some
way shape or form so essentially there's
there's little things there's spots
where the muscle fiber is attached to
the like connective tissue matrix that
surrounds each muscle fiber and also
runs through the muscle and it seems
like a lot of the actual like molecular
pathways that eventually trigger muscle
protein synthesis have a lot to do with
those little adhesion points and when
tension is put on the fiber and it kind
of pulls on those adhesion points that
activates like various kinase is that
then trigger the processes that
eventually lead to muscle protein
synthesis so those are our tension based
processes so the idea is you need to
both recruit motor units and then also
expose those fibers to enough tension
that it's going to to kick off all of
the hypertrophy cascade and the the
notion here is that with with weights
that aren't like super heavy so weights
that aren't like five rep max or below
you're probably not recruiting all of
your motor units from the first rep and
you can probably move each rep pretty
quickly and when you're moving a rep
pretty
quickly you you don't have enough time
to form enough actin-myosin crossbridges
within each fiber for there to be a ton
of tension on the fiber so basically
like if you're grinding a 1 rep max or
if you're doing like something
plyometric you're probably recruiting
all or most of your motor units for both
of those two things but there's way more
tension when you're doing the 1 rep max
because the plyometric is very explosive
the shortening velocity is high there's
just not that much time for too many
cross bridges to form to create tension
which is why like you know if you grind
out several sets of tend to failure you
grow quite a bit you do some jumps you
don't grow all that much so so that's
kind of the idea like the kernel of the
idea behind effective reps you need to
recruit those high threshold motor units
and you need to get movement velocity
low enough that each fiber can be
exposed to a whole lot of tension the
idea some people have is to maximize
tension on each fiber which they propose
will occur right before failure and this
ideas gotten a lot of traction right
like you did a little poll on your
Instagram the other day basically saying
like essentially the question was like
how favorably do you view this effective
reps idea was that essentially what they
asked yes so the original poll I think
had two options one was it's legit and
the other is it's bogus
and then like a bunch of people messaged
me it's like oh it's probably more
complicated than that it's like dude you
can only give two [ __ ] options for an
Instagram poll like calm down so then I
added another like slide to my Instagram
story that says like you can also
interpret this as like mostly correct or
like mostly incorrect and I added that
within like 30 minutes of the poll going
up but anyway so like 2,500 people voted
in that and it was like 62% in favor of
effective reps being a valid model and
38% against and so there's a there's
various like quite a few people have
have put forward various
ideas for effective reps Chris
Beardsley's model is probably the most
well known so that's what my article was
critiquing but James Krieger has put
forth a similar idea carljan oh and I'm
gonna butcher his name but I think he
pronounced it Bor hey but everyone calls
him borscht because I think no one knows
how to pronounce its name we're not
people to ask anyway so they've all put
forth various effective reps esque
concepts but Chris Beardsley's idea is
the one that has gotten the most
traction and it is essentially the idea
that the last five reps before failure
are the ones that are effective those
are the ones where basically all of the
motor units have been recruited and
there's going to be enough tension per
fiber to to trigger hypertrophy and he's
he has spelled it out in such a way that
at least makes it seem that each one of
those five would be similarly effective
so he's like gone through like different
scenarios like oh if you do you know
four sets to failure or four sets one
rep shy of failure four sets to rep shy
of failure like this is how many
effective reps you would get and that
very much makes it seem like it's not
like oh maybe the rep before failure is
the one that's actually the most
effective and like the one five reps out
is a little effective but not as close
like it's it's a pretty straightforward
model where basically if it's within
five reps of failure it counts if it's
more than five reps out it doesn't count
so like an implication of that is if you
did four reps or if you did four sets to
failure that would get you four more
effective reps than four sets one rep
shy of failure you get twenty effective
reps so the last five of each set if you
did four sets to failure you'd only get
sixteen effective reps or the last four
of each set if you did four sets one rep
shy of failure
so not another implication there is if
you you know kind of do traditional
strength training where you know you're
probably terminating most sets two to
three reps shy of failure then you would
probably need to do eight sets to get
the same hypertrophic effect as four
sets to failure so just kind of throwing
some some concrete implications of the
model out there and so the thing about
this concept of effective reps is it has
some degree of mechanistic support so
for example if you look at research
where like people are doing isometric
exercise at different percentages of
maximum voluntary isometric contraction
it seems like working up to about 80 85
percent of NVIC that's like the range in
which motor unit recruitment does
increase and past about 80 percent or so
most of the further increase in force
just has to do with increases in motor
unit firing rates and there's also some
research looking at surface EMG for
single joint exercises finding that when
you get about five-ish reps from failure
for single joint exercises EMG plateaus
and you don't get further increases in
EMG as you get closer to failure so EMG
isn't it's not like one-to-one the same
thing as motor unit recruitment but the
two things do correlate reasonably well
and there's also like direct evidence
showing that you do need pretty slow
contraction speeds to maximize per fiber
tension essentially because the rate at
which actin myosin detachment can occur
is like a pretty variable but the rate
at which attachment or the rate at which
detachment can occur is pretty variable
but the rate that attachment can occur
is fixed and reasonably low and so with
really high fiber sure
in velocities you get like fiber
detachment rates can exceed attachment
rate so only like a fairly small
percentage of your like actin and myosin
cross bridges potential are actually
forming but with slower contraction
velocities the attachment and detachment
rates can match up better and so you can
get much higher for per fiber tension so
anyway that that's the mechanistic idea
there is mechanistic evidence underlying
that and there is also some degree of
experimental evidence to back this up so
the two studies that I think most people
would cite as evidence for the concept
of effective reps is one back from like
2004 2005 by Gotoh at all and then a
more recent one by martyr le and
colleagues and so in the godo study
basically you had two groups doing four
sets of ten one of the group was taking
those sets to failure and the other
group was taking like a 30-second break
between reps five and six of each set
and so with that 30-second intercept
break they weren't taking each set to
failure because they were getting a
little bit of rest in between and in
that study they were doing knee
extensions and they were measuring quad
growth and they found that the group
doing those four doing those ten reps
straight through without the break in
the middle did grow considerably more it
was like two and a half times more and
then in the more recent martorelli study
untrained women were doing bicep curls
at 70% of their max one group was doing
three sets to failure one group was
doing three sets of seven which would
probably be five or six reps from
failure and one group was doing four
sets of seven which was like trying to
match volume load with the three sets to
failure group do you think seven is the
least common number of reps to prescribe
iFlex amazing thing I've never heard of
someone being like give me a good seven
here I don't see many fours either oh I
do fours all the time I don't think that
many people do force
talk to my client I see a lot of heavy
triples and then of course valve yeah
but ya don't see too many fours I do
fours all the time but sevens are off
the table I would never dare prescribe a
7 sure but anyway so in in the
martorelli study the the increase in
biceps thickness I think was like
eighteen and a half percent in the
failure group like eight and a half
percent in the four sets of seven group
and like two percent in the three sets
of seven group so pretty big difference
there so that's kind of like the
evidence in favor of this effective reps
model but there are problems with it so
the research show the research
suggesting increased motor unit
recruitment up to about eighty
eighty-five percent of one rep max or
about five reps shy of failure most of
that is looking at single joint
exercises and you can also find it some
with like multi joint exercises with
untrained lifters but there's actually
several studies using trained lifters
doing multi-joint exercises finding that
the prime movers might be pretty close
to full motor unit recruitment at
considerably lower loads further from
failure so there was a recent study by
Vanden tell our and colleagues looking
at the squat and it was looking at
quadriceps so I think every head of the
quads except for the vastus intermedius
it was looking at quadricep hamstring
and glute EMG with increasing loads and
found that with loads between like 50%
and 90% of one rep max for like the
first rep of each set quad EMG was the
same and so and and there's actually
modeling research by Bryant inand
colleagues using a measure called
relative muscular effort which is
essentially the the external moments
presented by an exercise divided by the
joint moments kind of measured in a
single joint way that
lifters can produce like in isolation
and so that study found their relative
muscular effort in the squat basically
didn't change with increased loads and
and so that does actually seem to match
with with EMG as well and so also in
that study it looked again at hamstring
and glute EMG and it did see that those
were going up with increased load and so
the quads are probably if you had to
choose one prime mover in the squat it
is probably the quads and so the prime
mover pretty high EMG from the get-go
some of the like secondary supporting
muscles increased EMG as load goes up
similar with an older study by McBride
and colleagues it looked at quad and
hamstring EMG with 70 80 and 90 percent
loads it found that quad EMG at 70
percent pretty much the same as 90% but
hamstring EMG again was much higher at
90 percent than 70 percent so again
prime mover EMG pretty high even a
fairly low loads like 70 percents
reasonably low but a secondary muscle in
that case the hamstrings ramping up as
load increases and then there was also a
study from a couple years back by
Crowell and golus looking at increasing
loads in the bench press and it found
that Peck EMG also basically the same
between 70 percent 1 rep max loads and
actual 1 rep max loads but the EMG of
the front delts triceps and maybe lats
also did go up with increasing loads so
again if you had to pick a prime mover
in the benchpress it's probably gonna be
the pecs don't tell Louie I said that
but this is the secondary muscles your
triceps front delts those EMG is going
up as loads increase so it very well
could be that kind of first assumption
of the effective reps model that you do
need for recruitment and you need to go
pretty close to failure or pretty heavy
loads to get that for recruitment I
think that is very much true with single
joint exercise
but I'm not confident that that is
actually true with trained lifters doing
multi-joint exercises especially if
you're interested in the prime movers so
for example if you're interested in
squatting for hamstring growth one
that's kind of dumb like we've written
about that on the site before but - if
you weren't doing that you know maybe it
would behoove you to go to failure on
every set but if you're squatting for
quad growth you know you may not have to
actually go that close to failure to
stimulate your quads pretty well and
then the second assumption there like
needing pretty slow contractile
velocities to achieve full tension on
each fiber I'm pretty skeptical of that
and the reason I'm skeptical of it is so
that's largely based on the load
velocity relationship or the the force
velocity curve we're at at higher forces
velocities lower at lower velocities or
at lower forces velocity is higher but
that again is established under unfitted
conditions
so essentially you know if you're having
a fibre contract against increasing
loads as the loads go up contraction
velocity decreases but under conditions
of fatigue it's not the exact same
relationship under conditions of fatigue
if velocity is go petite with the same
load just to be clear as velocities
going down force is also going down like
force intention aren't increasing as
velocity decreases as you do say like a
set of 12 - failure like velocity is
going to be lowest on the last rep
before failure but I don't think you can
make the case that per fiber tension is
higher at that point your fibers have
fatigued there's going to be some
metabolites in there that affect the
interactions between actin and myosin
and also like Central Drive is going to
decrease so
the the frequency with which or the
frequency at which motor units or the
motor nerves can reach depolarization
and send signals to the fibers like
firing rates that's going to be lower as
well so I don't think the lower
velocities closer to failure
during a set to failure with a fixed
load indicates higher tension per fiber
I think it indicates that you can't
produce as much tension per fiber so if
you're using hyper fiber tension as a as
a reason supporting the effective reps
model I don't think that you can make
that argument in the context of a set to
failure so lower velocity is lower
tension in that case not the same as
like the force velocity relationship
with changing loads when you're fresh so
anyway the the biggest thing I'm trying
to get at here is that the mechanistic
underpinnings of the effect of Reps
model they make sense insofar as
recruiting those highest threshold motor
units and exposing them to a fair amount
of tension those things make sense based
on what we mechanistically know about
hypertrophy but the idea that you
necessarily need to be within five reps
a failure to trigger those things I'm
less sold on I think you can get pretty
close to full motor unit recruitment for
the prime movers of multi-joint
exercises quite a bit further out from
failure and I don't actually think
you're maximizing per fiber tension as
you get closer to failure that doesn't
necessarily mean that you don't get more
growth closer to failure but I think the
the idea that that is what's maximizing
per fiber tension and that is then what
is promoting hypertrophy I think the
evidence in favor of that comes from
studies on the wrong context which is
looking at unfit eked fibers with
different loads versus under the
influence of fatigue taking the same
load to failure
so in the article on the website I would
I would recommend you check that out
because there's a pretty big part in the
middle of the article where I also
discuss a muscle fiber bait or a motor
unit based model of muscle fatigue from
potvin Potvin and colleagues and my
understanding is that it is the the most
generally accepted motor unit based
model of fatigue that is published in
the literature but it also doesn't make
sense to discuss on this podcast because
it's very very visual and you will get
bored as [ __ ] if I attempt to explain it
and I would also do a terrible job
explaining it so the the main point that
I wanted to extract from the Potvin
model is also just that like your very
highest threshold motor units probably
are never under maximal tension ever in
any context except for like a maximal
isometric so we have longitudinal
research from from morton and colleagues
out of stu phillips lab looking at fiber
type specific hypertrophy with like
training at 50% vs. 80% 1 rep max we see
that we see that both type 1 and type 2
fiber growth is pretty similar training
of both intensities but if you look at
pathans model like there's a very low
chance that most of your highest
threshold motor units are getting
anywhere particularly close to maximal
tension even as you approach failure
with like 50% NVIC contractions so I'm
I'm pretty skeptical that you you do
need to expose a fiber to maximal
tension for robust hypertrophy in the
first place so check out the article
look at look at the Potvin model stuff
I'm not going to attempt to explain it
in more depth than that here on the
podcast so I mean generally speaking it
sounds like there are smart people
who know their stuff who have talked
about this effective reps model mm-hmm
and it's not that the entire thing is
you know completely off base but it
sounds like the problem is when people
get extremely technical with the
theoretical underpinnings or take the
interpretation or the application
extremely literally is that like a fair
characterization it's like because I
mean theoretically we would know with
with training obviously we have to if
we're trying to induce hypertrophy we
have to apply tension to the fiber we
have to induce some semblance of fatigue
mm-hmm and that those two things are
probably both driving some degree of
hypertrophy and that if you are doing
these reps that are somewhere near
failure with reasonably heavy loads it's
at least getting you in the ballpark
right yeah so I think I think something
worth discussing is like why I wrote
this article in the first place
sure and I think it's that three reasons
I would say so the first reason is I
rarely critique ideas that I don't think
have much purchase with my audience so
like there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
that I generally disagree with that no
one or that like you know maybe 2% of my
audience would actually agree with you
were a really late adopter for urine
injections for example correct you
didn't really get into it you didn't
write about it much until recently right
so for the most part I'm not gonna
critique an idea if I don't think that
the people I'm reaching are the people
who need to be reached with the the
critique of that idea and so I know that
the effect of Reps model of hypertrophy
does have significant purchase within my
audience and so you know I'm not just
like crying out in the wilderness about
something that no one in my audience
actually believes and that the only
effect is just I'm preaching to the
choir and I'm gonna get kudos for
telling people [ __ ] that they already
agree with you know so that's reason
number one reason number two is so I
start pretty much anything
at the actual experimental evidence like
theories can sound good but if it
doesn't match what we've actually
observed it's you kind of have to go
back to the drawing board right and so
also in the article I looked at the
studies that had to my mind tested the
effect of reps model of hypertrophy idea
the most rigorously so these would be
studies with like quote-unquote normal
training so you know not looking at rest
pause or drop sets or anything like that
but just you know normal multi set
training with one group going closer to
failure or to failure every set and at
least one other group staying further
from failure than the other group that
are matched for intensity and either
matched for total number of sets done or
total number of reps done and when you
actually look at the experimental
evidence you don't actually see that
much like direct tangible evidence for
the effect of Reps model so those two
studies I previously mentioned by godo
and martorelli
they do provide strong evidence in favor
of the effect of Reps model of
hypertrophy there are six other studies
that kind of investigate the idea and
they just don't support this concept so
there's two other studies on untrained
lifters doing multi-joint exercises one
is by samson one is by no Brega they
tend to find no difference between
groups going to failure or not to
failure there's some issues with those
studies the Samson study the non failure
groups were still doing one set per week
to failure to four load progressions
sake and the Nobriga study the
conditions not going to failure we're
basically going to RP ten so you
essentially had two conditions that were
actually failing every set and the other
conditions basically going to failure
still but so like there are those four
studies and untrained lifters doing
single joint exercises and all together
they find that going to failure closer
to
failure causes about twice as much
growth in just the go to' and martorelli
studies which don't have those issues
similar to the other studies I mentioned
it's like a three fold difference so
like that looks like pretty strong
experimental evidence in favor of this
this model of hypertrophy that like
going close to failure and getting those
reps close to failure does make a big
difference but then there are four
studies on trained lifters that don't
they just don't support the idea at all
so there was a really recent study by
Karsten at all it looked at three
measures of hypertrophy one group doing
four sets attend failure one group doing
eight sets of five not anywhere close to
failure did find a significant
difference in favour of the failure
group four quad hypertrophy butt triceps
and delt hypertrophy were similar
between groups the the study that or one
of the studies that Eric Helms did for
his PhD who to be clear different person
than Eric Trexler Eric Helms is not on
this podcast so one of the studies he
did for his PhD it was looking at our PE
based training versus percentage based
training but he still got our P's for
people in both groups after each set in
the groups the group doing our PE based
training was training like 1 to 3 reps
closer to failure than the percentage
based group throughout the entire
program for benchpress and squat they
looked at PEC and quad growth and it was
similar between groups in spite of
differences in proximity to failure
between groups study by pareja blanco
comparing training force for sets of
squats with a 40% velocity loss per set
versus 4 sets with a 20% velocity loss
per set so basically you know if you
move the first rep at 1 meter per second
one group would terminate the set when
they got to a velocity of 0.6 the other
group would terminate when they got to a
velocity of 0.8 so in effect the the 40%
velocity loss group took like 56% of
their sets to failure
they did a lot of reps that were
grinders the
the 20% velocity loss group on average I
think the subjects only did like 10 reps
during the entire program where velocity
was less than like 0.5 m/s so like they
did basically no grindr's probably did
you know like virtually no quote/unquote
effective reps that study looked at quad
muscle volume and also fiber cross
sectional area of in the vastus
lateralis no significant differences
there and then a recent study by Carroll
was comparing one program where they did
where one of the groups took the last
set of every exercise to failure mostly
doing three sets per exercise so
probably one group like two ish reps
from one set to issue reps from failure
next set probably about one rep from
failure last set to failure so a fair
amount of like quote unquote effective
reps versus another group that was
training mostly like two to eight reps
from failure so like not that close
so it was rep since Ally yeah yeah so it
was basically one one day where they
were like two to four reps from failure
there so there were three days of
training but they only looked at quad
hypertrophy and the only like serious
quad exercise in in the study was squats
and so they were squatting twice a week
and so one group was was doing three
sets terminating and failure on the
third set both days and then the other
group was training like two to four reps
from failure one day and then like
pretty easy the second day okay and so
in that study they looked at a full
muscle and Tomiko cross sectional area
of the vastus lateralis they looked at
muscle thickness of the vastus lateralis
and they looked at fiber cross sectional
area for type 1 and type 2 fibers the
only significant difference between
groups was anatomical cross sectional
area of the quads which was in favor of
the group training further from failure
and the other three measures kind
leaned in favor of that group as well
and so basically what you see when you
look at the experimental evidence is in
untrained subjects doing single joint
exercises the concept of effective reps
tracks pretty well with the experimental
evidence groups training closer to
failure doing more of those reps within
five reps of failure do see considerably
more hypertrophy and in the two studies
that don't that didn't have like the
well was the other group actually
training to failure sometimes issue it
was like a three-fold difference in
hypertrophy like that's that's pretty
good but then in the four studies on
trained lifters mostly doing multi joint
exercises there's no difference
whatsoever I think it was like an
average four across like all measures of
hypertrophy in those studies it was like
an average of like a nine percent
increase for the group doing fewer quote
unquote effective reps and like an eight
and a half percent increase in the group
doing like more quote unquote effective
reps so like I mean maybe it only
applies to untrained lifters which is
something but also probably aren't the
people that that are digging into like
mech mechanisms of hypertrophy type
articles on the Internet yeah it's like
I'm three weeks in but I'd really like
to learn more yeah and so so that was
the second reason so I wanted to talk
about this one significant purchase
within my audience to doesn't seem to
track that well but the actual like
longitudinal experimental evidence and
then the third reason was that kind of I
don't think that we should have models
that are more specific than what our
current level of knowledge grant grants
us the right to have so essentially if
you have really granular evidence then
you can make a granular model based on
that evidence and and we just don't have
enough granular evidence to know that
like you know five reps from failure
that's the line that's when reps become
effective and so like a soft version of
the effect of reps idea would be like
well to maximize high perch
be on a per set basis you have to go at
least kind of close to failure I don't
think anyone is going to argue that you
know you take 70% of your max you do
three sets to twelve or you do three
triples again at 70% which is probably
going to be like 9 or 10 reps from
failure I don't think anyone is going to
argue that you're going to get similar
per set hypertrophy there I don't think
anyone would like everyone would argue
well you have to go at least kind of
close to failure right if you don't go
until [ __ ] gets hard you're not gonna
grow you know so like a soft version of
the effect of reps idea is that well you
do have to kind of go close to failure
to grow but at that point it's not an
effective reps model that's that's an
answer you could get from literally
anyone at the gym like you ask them how
close do I have to go to failure to grow
some people are gonna say I got to go to
failure every set some people are gonna
say yeah to 2 or 3 reps from failures
probably fine but no one's gonna say
like oh man to maximize growth got to
stay 10 reps away like at that point
it's not it's not its own model anymore
it's just [ __ ] that everyone already
believes you know right and so like the
more specific version of the effect of
reps idea that like reps get more
effective as you get closer to failure
and it's really just those last five
that count we don't have enough granular
we don't have granular enough evidence
to confidently say that and we have
evidence contradicting it so I have
issues with specific models that are
more specific than we can can
justifiably derive so here's my question
I spend more time keeping an eye on the
nutrition and body comp related chatter
mm-hmm not as much on the training side
my outside observation was some period
of time ago everybody was obsessed with
volume load like their tonnage even for
their training and then people started
bringing up these hypothetical questions
of like well
if I did that tonnage but arranged it in
a completely ludicrous way mm-hmm such
that nothing was ever acutely
challenging yeah yeah did this just kind
of evolved to fill that gap like to help
explain like well no you got to do
something that's kind of tough maybe so
not to not to toot my own horn too much
but I kind of think that stronger by
science started changing that
conversation back in 2013 2014 we
published a guest article from Nathan
Jones that like was the first thing I
saw that got pretty popular and it went
a little bit viral arguing that hey
volume load is dumb like probably as
long as sets are pretty close to failure
you can count hard sets and that's going
to predict hypertrophy reasonably well
so 2013 2014 he he did a good job
summarizing the evidence that was there
but there weren't that many studies kind
of to support or refute that idea back
then and then a couple years later like
either 2015 2016 there abouts there was
an explosion of research in that area
especially like high load versus low
load stuff and so I basically wrote like
an expanded version of Nathan's article
incorporating the research that had come
out in the past couple years I think
called the high perch like the quote
unquote hypertrophy range factor fiction
question mark and it incorporated like a
lot more of the recent research and it
basically made the same point that
volume load is dumb and as long as sets
are pretty close to failure you can
count hard sets and so I think that's
when the conversation started shifting
like that's when I started that's when I
started seeing people talk about volume
load and then like a dozen people jump
down their throat and say volume loads
dumb it's hard sets so I think that I
think that a
affective reps is kind of a more
granular version of hard sets like it's
trying to quantify what hard is and kind
of make the claim that going to failure
does matter is going to get you more
growth per set than staying like two rep
shy of failure so I think it's just a
more granular idea that is similar to
the hard sets concept but it is more
granular in a way that's not fully
justified yeah I mean I shared your
article this most recent one on social
media and someone kind of comment is
like why not just do hard sets which I
mean like fair enough hard sets that
there it's it's a logical I mean it's a
solid way to operationalize things but I
think this most recent article makes you
consider the idea of if you do hard sets
how hard should have set be you know
what I mean like exactly how literally
do we take this idea of effective reps
and say well if you stop to shy of
failure that's objectively worse than
stopping one Shia failure you know what
I mean and so my response is like yeah
you can do hard sets and that's still
fine but but how hard mm-hmm and I think
using hard sets as a framework and then
diving into this article of talking
about okay so how hard are we talking I
think you walk away from from the
article with a better understanding of
from a practical perspective how
nitpicky do we have to get about that
proximity to failure when programming
yes so I the the conclusion I basically
came to is I think like as is often the
case the stuff that like big jacked
people were saying 20 years ago is
probably right
so like compound lifts two to three reps
from failure probably fine like you
probably don't need to push every set of
compound exercise to failure to maximize
growth on a per set basis but but you
very well may need to go to failure for
single joint stuff so like you know stay
two or three
reps from failure when you squat then
hop over to the knee extension and you
know [ __ ] give give it everything you
got
you know and I think one I think that's
what the experimental evidence supports
like the stuff on single joint training
going to failure does seem like a pretty
big deal stuff on multi joint stuff you
know - two or three reps further from
failure doesn't really seem to have much
of an effect on hypertrophy so probably
don't need to take that it's close to
failure which again like that's that's
what people have been saying for a long
time and I think it's probably mostly
right but yeah so just to shift gears
slightly I think one of the I think one
of the like interpretations that came
out of this article that I don't fully
agree with and something that I've seen
like levied at me before is that I'm
like anti training to failure because I
mean the the basic difference between
the idea I like which is hard sets and
the idea of effective reps is basically
like you know I say yeah I probably need
to push everything to at least like two
to three reps I failure that's probably
advisable at least for i purge fee maybe
maybe not for strength in some context
but I mean the main difference is just
really oh those last two or three reps
from - failure like are those effective
or not so I think some people get the
idea that I am anti training to failure
and I'm not like I think it's quite
useful in some contexts and so I think
the first thing training to failure
gives you is I think it's good for idiot
proofing your program against laziness
and so one of the things I see with some
people and we've talked about this
before is that when some folks use like
our PE or reps and reserve based
training their mark and [ __ ] down as an
RPE eight that's just not like you look
at it they still have like six reps in
the tank they never do anything remotely
hard and there
yeah and one of the things that's
striking when you start reading research
is you see a lot of longitudinal
training studies that recruit folks who
have an average of three like three four
or five years of training experience
they put them on a really basic program
for like ten weeks and then they you
know like muscle cross sectional area
increases ten percent and they get like
twenty percent stronger on their main
lifts and if you're a strength coach and
you've been working with someone for
five years and they started with you
when they were untrained you're not
getting their muscles ten percent bigger
and putting twenty percent on their
lifts in ten weeks like it just doesn't
happen but these programs are really
basic but in the vast majority of
research all sets are taken to failure
and there's also research looking at how
lazy most people are in most of their
training so Eric Helms distinctly
different Eric than the one on this
podcast I've met him but I'm not him
correct yeah just to be clear he
reviewed a study from mass like maybe a
year and a half ago looking it was a
super straightforward study they
basically like plucked people out of the
campus gym at some college and asked
them if you were bench-pressing and you
were doing sets of ten what weight would
you work with and so one like those
people probably exaggerated a little bit
just because if you ask someone how much
you bench most people round up not down
you know but so they ask them how much
would you do four sets of ten they told
him a number I think it was probably an
over estimate whatever and then they
brought them in the next day or like a
couple days later whatever and just put
them on a bench like loaded them or warm
them up and then threw the weight they
did four sets of ten on the bar and just
have them do a set to failure and I
forget the exact numbers from that study
but I want to say like forty percent of
the folks did 16 or more reps which I
mean you know maybe they don't do binge
first in their workout and like they do
some pre fatigue stuff or like they do
20 sets of bench and so they need to
start with a conservative number for 10
like those are possibilities but no I
don't think that applies to most of them
most people you start a workout if
you're gonna bench in the workout bench
is your first exercise ya probably gonna
do three or four sets
so like dude a hefty chunk of the people
in that study we're just training lazy
like they never did anything that I
would call a hard set or that probably
anyone except them would call a hard set
but like they thought that that was an
appropriate way to Train bench press you
know so one of the things you see in the
research is you take these people who
claim to have prior training experience
make them start pushing every set to
failure and then magically within about
three months they get a lot bigger and a
lot stronger so I don't think training
to failure is bad but I think that it
does idiot-proof your program against
laziness if you go until you can't do a
rep no one's going to say that that was
not a hard set so one everyone would
agree you need to train pretty hard to
maximize growth if you don't have much
experience training to failure or any
experience training to failure that's a
good way to make sure your program is
hard so that's the first thing I would
say you look like you're about to say
something I was gonna say I have advice
that people shouldn't take but it
actually is useful it's just dangerous
so don't do it but so when I bench in
the gym I never get a spotter but a lot
of times people will come up and ask if
they can spot me but do you mind if I
just spot you because I feel like you're
gonna die and so I feel like that's a
really good litmus test for like exactly
how much are you short changing your RPS
if people start offering to spot you and
just but please just let me just let me
keep an eye on you it probably means
you're pushing your RPE is pretty hard
that you're you're at least getting up
there yeah and then what you can do if
you want if you need a witty
fonts and you want to say no you just
say if I don't get the rep I don't want
to live to know about it I think we'll
think you're really tough nice and so
the other thing that I would say pretty
strongly in favor of training to failure
is I think that if you do want to do
submaximal training and use are peas or
reps and reserved to to manage that I
think there's value in spending some
time when you do a lot of training to
failure just so when your program says
you know rp8 two reps in reserve you
know what that [ __ ] feels like and I
think that like if you've never gone to
failure I just don't know that I would
feel confident that you accurately know
when you're two reps from failure
because I think that I think that's a
lot harder than a lot of people realize
it is like like I know so for example
like I have a fair amount of experience
doing like Shaco style training that
that's just feeding you triples at 80%
and like doubles at 85 percent until
until the cows come home and like a
triple at 80 percent it's not easy like
you still have plenty of reps in reserve
like for most people it's probably at
least three reps in reserve for me when
I'm fresh it's probably five or six but
like a triple at 80% if you have a
pretty high squat it's not an easy set
you know do four or five six of those
like you feel like you got a pretty good
workout in and when I get in Chico mode
those you know by the time I get like
two or three sets in I'm like [ __ ] like
this is hard and I think part of it is
kind of the mental grind but at any
point I could just say well I'm doing a
set to failure now and get like eight or
nine reps you know so I think that if
you and like I can step back and know
that and know that like no I can
definitely do this next set like I feel
the deep Chico ache in my thighs but I
know I can
this next set it's not actually that
hard I just don't want to do it but I I
think that yeah if you don't have if you
don't have much experience training to
failure like you know it's not that
you're doing nothing if you're doing
sets of ten with your sixteen rep max
it's just probably not as hard as you
think it is and you may think you only
have like two or three reps you could do
but you can actually do way more so so I
think that there's value in in spending
some time going to failure just so you
can like accurately use submaximal
training down down the line and then the
the biggest thing people will say
against training to failure is that it's
going to like dramatically increase your
injury risk and I'm actually not so sure
about that either so I I know that the
the hip thing to say these days is that
there's no correlation between technique
and injury rates whatsoever I think that
I think that that idea is maybe more
true than some people believe but I
don't think it's completely true like I
think if you go to failure like to true
failure until you actually miss for like
squats and deadlifts week in and week
out that will probably elevate your
injury risk some people are probably
gonna get mad at me because that's not a
hard line enough statement some people
are probably going to get mad at me
because I said that there's any
relationship whatsoever between
technique and injury risk but I just
don't think your form breaking down
going to failure on squats and deadlifts
is a great idea
[ __ ] fight me anyways so I do think
that like in that context yeah yeah
training to failure may increase your
injury risk form break down your
squatting and dead lifting like 500
pounds with a bunch of spinal flexion
yeah it's not good but I also think that
that doesn't apply to like pretty much
any other lifts so I mean take take
bench press for example if you have a
spotter
and so you don't have to worry about
like crushing your sternum or ribcage or
whatever what's actually gonna go that
bad if you push a set to failure
like what what like joint or tissue is
going to be exposed to so much like
extreme elevation and stress that bad
stuff is gonna happen or like [ __ ]
pull downs what's gonna what's gonna go
wrong if you take a set of pull downs to
failure well I and I think we can kind
of get an idea of of the of the fact
that going to failure doesn't
dramatically change injury risk just by
looking at the injury rates comparing
strength sports and bodybuilding so
there's I think like two or three
studies looking at at injury rates and
bodybuilding and like two two three four
studies for powerlifting weightlifting
strongman like for each sport and you
tend to see you tend to see injury rates
for bodybuilding that's like maybe half
an injury to one and a half injuries per
thousand hours of training and for the
strength sports it's anywhere between
like two and five and so like injury
rates do pretty reliably seem to be
lower in bodybuilders and obviously this
isn't true for all individuals at all
time but I don't think anyone's gonna
give me much pushback when I claim that
bodybuilders go to failure for a lot of
exercises a lot more frequently than
strength athletes do and so I don't
think the actual kind of like real world
type evidence like actually looking at
injury rates suggests that training to
failure under most contexts is really
that bad for injury risk so so I do
think I do think training to failure is
fine
under most contexts I think it helps
idiot-proof your program against not
training hard I think it's useful down
the line if you want to do RP and our IR
based stuff I don't think it's ideal for
strength development I think that you
know being able to get in high quality
sets being able to do more of them
by not pushing close to failure it's
probably going to be clutch I think your
training frequency in the amount of
times you can practice a motor pattern
in the week is going to be higher if you
don't train to failure just because it's
not going to take quite as long to
recover from that training session like
I I do think there there are a lot of
contexts where it makes more sense and
you will probably get better results not
training to failure but I'm definitely
not anti training to failure alright so
if you want to take a deeper dive into
some of the evidence we've talked about
if you want to get a deeper grasp on
this entire concept of effective reps
and what evidence supports it what
evidence maybe doesn't support it again
that article is that stronger by science
calm / effective reps yeah in just one
very final thing I want to I want to
note about the idea of effective reps
and Chris Beardsley's
version of it in particular this this
was in my outline and I forgot to say it
on the front end one thing I want to
make clear is that my article is
critiquing the version of his ideas that
has gotten really popular online which
is is a bit of a simplification of what
it seems he actually believes about the
topic itself so I want to make it clear
that that I really like Chris I agree
with most of the things he has to say
and his actual ideas about hypertrophy
are probably a bit more nuanced than
what is getting shared on the internet
constantly so I want I want to make it
clear that I'm critiquing kind of like
the internet hive mind version of
Chris's model and not everything he has
ever said about the subject okay so ooh
to play us out now to play us out a very
very upsetting news came down the line
on a previous episode we mentioned that
Ohio State it's the football team that
Greg and I root for there's also a
university associated with the football
team the university the
they applied to trademark the word the
and at the time we were talking about it
was still up in the air well it was the
correct thee it's not the Ohio State
University yes the word is thee and so
they just got word back the initial
application has been refused by the US
the United States Patent and Trademark
Office
so some career politician bureaucrat
probably with a political axe to grind
probably part of the deep state swamp
people decided that they wanted to kick
this application back and deny it but
hope is not lost Ohio State says that
they have several legal avenues that
they can pursue they're still on the
case they are gonna make this happen ok
so it was a little setback I wanted to
inform people who were maybe waiting to
hear an update yes we had a small
setback in the courts there or I guess
at the US Patent Office so just to be
clear a setback in the courts right
correct yeah I setback in the courts but
the good news is we are still when I say
we I mean the university is still
working hard to make that happen and the
other good news is Ohio State is
two-and-oh and looking great alright
thank you for listening to another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast after the music we've got an
interview with Lauren Cole Enzo simple
we hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
[Music]
so Lauren you recently completed your
master's degree with Bill Campbell over
at University of South Florida and now
you're doing your PhD at McMaster
correct with Stu Phillips that's right
so while I was working as a trainer I
sort of became aware of this area of
research and connected with Bradshaw
involved volunteered in his lab for a
bit and he recommended bill Campbell's
program so I was there for two years and
I have been in Hamilton for about a week
and a half very cool how you liking it
so far it is an adjustment but we're
making progress made by day
very good so yeah I mean what's really
cool is if you kind of look back over
the last few years you've got quite a
quite a coaching tree that you come from
in terms of your academic training so
you you intern with Bradshaw and felt a
little bit you did a master's with Bill
Campbell you did an internship with Andy
Galpin over in California while you were
there you made a pilgrimage to the glute
lab under the tutelage of Brett
Contreras for like a weekend and then
now you're with Stu Phillips in Canada
so that that's a extensive list of
really the heavy hitters in the
evidence-based fitness side of things so
do you have a PhD topic yet I don't ok
well it's only been a week so I guess
that's fair so I've been focusing on
things like getting an ID and getting my
furniture yeah health insurance you know
just it's kind of like the penalty that
you pay when you abandon your country is
you have to go through some of the
unpleasant processes of reestablishing
that stuff now one of the things I want
to talk to you about today is the study
that you recently completed for your
master's thesis so the title I believe
is high in moderate volumes facilitate
similar muscular adaptations and
resistance trained women and full
disclosure I collaborated on this
project a little bit frankly I I think I
didn't kind of most of the work but I'm
still going to ask you questions to kind
of lead the conversation along so
you mind telling us kind of why this
project like what inspired you to set
out to look into this question so I
actually went to the University of South
Florida with the intention of doing this
study so if you can sort of put that in
perspective that was mid 2017 and volume
was a very hot topic I guess it still is
but at that point there was really a
lack of work in women and particularly
in trained women so I kind of wanted to
fill that void in comparing a what we
deemed a moderate volume to a sort of
unreasonably high volume and so how did
you go about kind of setting those
volumes like determining what was a
moderate and what was a high volume
first I decided to just have the volume
discrepancy be in the lower body so we
would just measure strength and muscle
thickness in lower body sites so it was
although a full body program very lower
body focused just because I found that
in some other studies that looked like
they were doing these full body workouts
but a lot of the exercises were not
necessarily hitting the muscle groups
that they were testing in anyway so I
wanted it to be sort of as relevant to
the test as possible in terms of the
volume but no time in terms of the
number of sets that we established as as
moderate and high that was basically
looking at the the moderate as what was
then sort of the perceived upper limit
where by which there wasn't enough
evidence to determine whether you would
continue to grow at the time Brad had
just published a meta-analysis looking
at you know three sets is better than
one five sets is better than three ten
sets is better than five but after that
we're not sure what happens
so the moderate volume group was
I'm performing 12 sets for the lower
bodies three times per week and the
higher the high-volume group is
performing what ended up being 81 sets
total so 27 sets three times per week so
that's really high volume how did the
how did the participants react to that
kind of volume so it is high but if you
think about the other studies that
describe this as sets per muscle group
per week then it wouldn't be as crazy so
if this was a mix of compound exercises
they were doing squats already Elle's
hip thrusts and leg extensions leg curls
cable abduction so it you know it was a
lot of volume but I'll just kind of put
that in context in terms of how they
handled it it was a really wide spectrum
of response I'd say the moderate volume
group were was completely fine they were
in and out in 40 minutes
some of them complained that it wasn't
enough work and then with the high
volume there was there were people who
seemed totally unaffected by it easily
to recover happy to show up every week
three days per week and then there were
people who were complaining dying etc
right so so just to get that get our
heads around the methods here so we're
talking there 37 resistance trained
women right that's right about 23 years
old and what was the the definition for
resistance train there they had to have
been resistance training for regularly
for the past two years and also have
been squatting regularly for the past
year okay cool and so you're training
them in the lab three days a week right
that's right so three nine consecutive
days a week for eight weeks the protocol
the exercise program was the same for
each session it was just that difference
in number of sets
and they were not training to failure we
cut off each set two reps from failure
cool and so the three days a week were
those all three of those were lower body
it was technically full-body but it was
a vastly lower lower body exercises as
the majority of the program and then at
the end of the workout they would do two
sets of an upper body push and two sets
of an upper body pull so so going into
this project you know there's been
several studies over the last few years
of comparing different volume levels
specifically in male subjects and I
think by and large kind of the
prevailing theory is that volume seems
to really dictate a lot when it comes to
strength and hypertrophy gains but then
theoretically there's got to be some
kind of upper limit where the
diminishing returns just get to the
point where why bother doing more you
know so it sounds like you were kind of
trying to do similar work in women and
see like okay if we do like a pretty
reasonable reasonable volume or a
super-high one you know does the high
volume stuff really pay off is that
basically what you're getting at here
that's right and that was also the
reason for having a fairly big
difference so you're the high volume
group was doing more than twice the
volume on a completely set basis than
the moderate volume group so we're
really trying to push that and to see is
there does it plateau do you regress and
try to kind of hit on that point if it
exists what what uh what are the kind of
outcomes that you're looking at we
measured muscle thickness using
ultrasound at in the front and the back
of the thigh and also the side so you
can think you know rectus femoris vastus
lateralis in the in the quad and then
hamstrings and glutes okay cool and so I
mean going into the study what were you
expecting to to find with this big
discrepancy in volume like what was the
hypothesis going into it
I had a feeling that strength would not
be different and I was right it was
exactly the foam in both groups and that
and what the strength measure was a 6rm
squat okay I didn't think the high
volume group would grow more and did
that pan out it did not
we had one statistically significant
finding in the lateral side in favor of
the high volume group but given the lack
of difference in all the other muscle
thickness site measures I'm not putting
in too much stock in that frankly but
just took sort of look at these these
types of studies as a whole it's really
hard to compare them because for example
you know my subjects grew about one to
five percent over eight weeks and you
look at some other studies and there's
way more growth in similar time frames
so it's tough to to see well what's the
norm or is it just how we're measuring
it do you do you think that was just
because your subjects were more highly
trained than than most of the prior
cohorts in the research I'm sure that
that had something to do with it but
even looking at some of the more recent
work the Schoenfeld paper that came out
last year the barb although I believe
that's how you pronounce it that was up
and they were those were both in trained
subjects and the the growth in both of
those studies was just way way way more
than what I witnessed so if not the
training status I mean what do you
attribute that to that's it's sort of a
mystery to me on it in trying to in
China compare this I'm just seeing yeah
a lot of it I think it's tough to kind
of reconcile the literature as a whole
at this point and I think part of that
some of the papers don't even report
actual millimeter thickness they're
reporting just p-values or effect sizes
in the more recent work has started
sharing oh you know this was the pre the
post the change but the the change over
time in my study was very small and that
honestly I think that makes some sense
to me as a trained person to let's say
to add ten percent to your quad in eight
weeks seems a little bit far-fetched
yeah I agree I see that all the time and
that's always the first thought that
comes to mind it's like look man like
I've trained a lot of people and I don't
I don't see that many people who've been
training hard for two or three years
like increasing any measure of muscle
size ten percent in six to eight weeks
like you just don't see that like you do
have individuals occasionally you have
results like that but like group results
yeah so it makes me think that
occasionally the the criteria are kind
of lacks so you know if they say we need
someone to be training for two years
it's like you know maybe if someone has
kind of like gone to the gym on and off
for two years they kind of slip into the
sample versus people who've like
actually been training for two years you
know yeah I mean absolutely and as you
both know recruitment for these kinds of
studies is a challenge and so although
you'd love for everybody to be equally
trained that's just never gonna happen I
feel like that's something that you is
kind of lost on people that have never
had to work through the logistics of
doing this kind of study but it's like
the ideal scenario is you're gonna find
somebody that's super into lifting and
has been training like crazy for
hopefully years mm-hmm
and is willing to hand over all of their
training decisions to you for an in the
for a long period of time and they know
it's not even a personalized program
it's just like well you're either gonna
get a or B you know in and they know
it's not just that it's not personalized
but that it's not necessarily going to
be like Oh one-size-fits-all program
that's attempting to be quote unquote
optimal like you're going into it with a
hypothesis like you got a 50-50 chance
that you're getting the program that
even the researcher doesn't think is
great you know yeah definitely
I mean like link reg said I think you
know what did you say was that generally
like the mean percentage growth you were
seeing in your ultrasound measurements
it was about 1 to 5 percent yeah I mean
if it was a six week or eight week study
eight weeks yeah if you promise me three
percent over the next eight weeks like
I'll take that immediately so like I
think and just for context you know
we're we're so those those actual
numbers are things like a millimeter two
millimeters sometimes a little bit more
than that but you know so think the
thickness of two pennies
oh you're that's not visible growth yeah
so after doing the study Oh being the
person that ran it I'm surprised you
didn't call me out when I slipped in
that comment that I did all the work
because I basically did none of the work
but I guess you're just gonna let that
slide after going through all this and
being there for all the training
sessions seeing how people respond to
the training like what's your main
takeaway in terms of like practical
conclusions when you look back at this
how can somebody actually use the
results to inform their training well
first and foremost you know take all of
these results with a grain of salt
because Eric did the statistics and I
obviously need to redo them just oh oh
[ __ ]
the statistics are fine we've got we've
got a world star moment about to go down
here in terms of practical takeaways I
mean one of the things that bothers me
when people look at studies
this is they're looking for the paper to
tell them what to do to tell you how to
train and that's this really silly way
and so we use this kind of use these
findings because the one of the most
interesting things about this kind of
study is you see all right this happened
on average it's not that interesting but
then you look at the individual response
and it's really interesting because
you're getting you're seeing hey this
program was great for somebody and
terrible for someone else and you see
that not only with with the muscle
growth but definitely with strength as
well you're you have somebody who got
five pounds weaker and somebody who put
80 pounds on their squad and part of
that yes I think training status going
in but there's clearly also this
question of volume and other variables
it's not one size fits all so I think as
an individual these papers give you
maybe a general place to start or as a
coach right but then if you're really
looking to optimize your own programming
then it's experimentation to really find
what works for you you're not getting
that from a paper I I do have one
question
so did you kind of like I don't know
informally shot down or like take notes
of which individuals on the high-volume
program were really struggling versus
which ones seemed to be more or less
doing fine because I would be interested
in in whether there would be a
difference between those folks like my
my kind of mental model here is that
more volume is better as long as you can
recover from it and it's not just
beating you [ __ ] so like I would kind of
think that the the more interesting
variable is a necessarily volume itself
but kind of like how people are
responding to the volume so like I would
think the people who were beat to hell
from the high volume would probably not
do better than the moderate
group or perhaps even do worse and then
the people who were on the high-volume
who were handling it quite well would
would probably do better than the
moderate volume group like that's that
would be kind of my rough hypothesis so
I'm just wondering if you like jotted
that down anywhere for kind of like an
informal analysis sure I mean it's hard
because there's so much that goes into
it that we have no control over
oh for sure lifestyle stress sleep all
that you know we have the resources to
to closely monitor all of the variables
that are going to go into recovery but I
would say um a lot of it was outside
stress so it seemed you know the the
people who just had more going on in
their lives this is you know not
shocking but the the students who were
students and jobs and were maybe in a
difficult major they tended to be having
a harder time with the high volume
whereas some of the other students who
maybe didn't have as much going on in
life were able to handle it better but
that's a really loose statement and I'm
probably not that helpful no I got you
that that makes sense and and so like if
if you did kind of find what I'm
hypothesizing here it would be like kind
of a two-way interaction like it wasn't
necessarily the greater volume that's
doing it or is it just they were the
ones that had lifestyles more conducive
to getting good results so ultimately it
may not mean anything I should mention
we we also assessed salivary cortisol at
baseline and post eight weeks and I have
not yet looked at the cortisol level in
comparison to maybe the progress that
they made on each program mostly because
statistician didn't give me the results
in totally
um but you you that's insane you texted
me at like five and some like here's
some quarters all day how do they look
mm-hmm I I did I mean like immediately
drop to everything except that I emailed
them to you two weeks ago yeah but I
wasn't I didn't care at that emailed
them to me and texted me and said I need
these now than I would have done them
then it's interesting that you know then
I'm coming on your podcast today so all
of a sudden time to prioritize my
cortisol listen the stats are fantastic
these are incredible stat you never seen
stats like these so I think you should
be happy that you got them so quickly as
far as I'm concerned the turnaround time
was like three hours moving on what was
interesting though just at first glance
is the range of cortisol levels so it's
my understanding that maybe an average
in kind of young people it would be
about 20 and they range from 5 to 35 in
our subjects which was pretty astounding
yeah and cortisol is just such a tricky
hormone I mean when we've we've used it
in previous studies I've been involved
with with physique athletes mm-hmm
throughout prep and recovery and there
are just so many things that influence
it I mean you you can get some pretty
wild numbers with cortisol just from I
mean the way you view it as a researcher
is you're simply looking at
physiological stressors but like you
can't control the fact that somebody had
a breakup three days ago and they've got
a final exam in two days and yeah
cortisol numbers you can just get pretty
wild pretty quick depending on these
other stressors that in many cases are
extraneous to anything you can control
or we're just that it's someone's first
time ever being in a research lab and
they're nervous sure yeah definitely
that's not to be overlooked and this is
the simple fact that
just measuring it once throughout the
day is a for sure a limitation yeah yeah
now I think when people look at the
literature comparing all these different
volumes there's been a lot of studies
over the last few years that kind of fit
that paradigm generally speaking I mean
what's your take on when you have
something I mean you have somebody that
maybe you're gonna coach and they come
to you and say all right let's start me
with a program what's your view on where
to set that volume getting started I
would err on the side of lower unless
they're already doing more but I think
we all make the mistake of doing way too
much way too early on and it's just
another opportunity to get injured it's
probably not helping you progress any
faster you know if I can grow doing five
sets a week then I should do that for as
long as it's working and then make the
adjustment instead of unnecessarily
doing 35 sets a week yeah and so do you
think that this relationship with volume
and growth and strength adaptations do
you suspect that this is because you
know you set out to do this study in
females who tend to be underrepresented
in this in this field in terms of you
know research participants do you
suspect that those guidelines differ
between men and women I I think that we
we don't know that yet I know there's a
fair amount of speculation on women can
handle more volume and women don't to
rest as long and I don't know that that
all that is very conclusive and I'd say
that sure on that on the individual
level there seems to be a big big range
of what what's gonna work for you but we
I don't think there's enough
studies comparing trained men and
trained women on the same from a
protocol and so it's kind of hard to
compare apples and oranges with you know
one study with trained men and one study
with trained women no I I agree
one of the really striking things when
you look at the literature is like how
many research questions have a ton of
studies in men and like no studies and
women are like maybe one study so like
for example the low load very high rep
training versus more like moderate load
like sets of eight to twelve type stuff
until there were there were two more
studies published in women like two or
three months ago but until then like
there were there were like fourteen
studies in men and there was one study
in women from back in like 2009 so like
how can you like there was there was a
body of literature in men that you could
draw conclusions from and then like one
study in women that she had to look at
at me like well hope they did that one
right so yeah like that's definitely a
good point a lot of what we know we just
kind of think slash hope that what we've
learned about in men carries over to
women as well and and in a lot of cases
it does but there's just not as much
research on women to be able to make
that comparison like you're talking
about yeah I mean people are we
published recently out of Andy's lab we
were looking at the fiber type in these
elite athletes men and women and there's
this sort of prevailing thought that
women possess more type two type one
fibers and we didn't find that in these
kind of elite athletes so I think
there's and not to say oh well everyone
else is wrong but with fiber type
analysis there's a lot of nuance based
on this particular technique that you
use
and so I think that some of that and and
probably some other kind of assumptions
of sex difference are will continue to
evolve as we do more research and as we
also kind of refine our techniques for
analysis now I'm glad you brought that
up because this summer you went out and
interned and Andy's lab and I know
looking at that paper you make a big
distinction between two different ways
to do this fiber typing analysis and
there's the homogenate composition and
then the the single fiber kind of method
for analysis do you mind explaining that
to me as if I were an idiot sure it's
okay pathetically this was a really
totally hypothetically um my experience
in Andy's lab was really valuable
because I think even if you're somebody
who reads a lot of papers where they're
reporting fiber type distribution it's
tough to truly understand well do we
care that one of us was homogenate and
one of this was single fiber and work
and can we compare those those papers
that we know can we group all of this
fiber type findings together and then
the answer is probably not so with the
homogenous you're basically taking the
sample and grinding it up and so you
have multiple different fibers and
subsequently fiber types within that
particular sample so then we're looking
at separating that mixture of proteins
based on the molecular weight and the
homogenous quantifies the percent area
that is occupied by your type one type
two a and type two X it does not
distinguish between the hybrid fiber
types so if you think of this actually
being on a kind of spectrum of myosin
heavy chain content then you're going
from the type line which is slow
to the type 2x are super fast but along
the way you also have these hybrids so
you have a type type 1 slash type 2a and
a type 2 a slash type 2 X and the
homogeneous can't identify the those
hybrids and so it tends to overestimate
the type 1 and the type 2 X yeah I think
I think that's an awesome point just to
interject I don't think a lot of people
are aware of the continuity in Muslim
fiber typing you know what I mean I
think a lot of people think there are
these three very neat bins of 1/2 a and
2 X and the whole concept that we're
really looking at more of a continuum
than three completely distinct things I
think is lost on a lot of people well
that's because that's because all of the
like exercise physiology textbooks that
you learn in undergrad are based on
research from like the [ __ ] seventies
man like like I don't think that's a
blind spot for people who aren't trying
to educate themselves I think that's
people just assuming that textbooks are
much more up-to-date than they are like
I know that's what I thought until like
I said something and then Andy Galpin
like saw what I posted and probably
could have torn me a new one but was way
more polite than I probably deserved
he was like check out my 55 minute
physiology videos on this topic and I
did and it just blew my mind because
like I had been told for the past like
five years of like hey this is how it is
and that's how like all of the basic
textbooks lay it out and that's you know
an understanding that's outdated by a
solid 30 years I think there's also this
I think it's represented as if oh this
fiber is type 1 and period end of story
but there's no explanation of what does
it actually mean to be type 1 and it if
its type 1 today does that mean its type
1 forever and that's another sort of
interesting body of work right now just
showing the plasticity of the fiber type
you know it that especially with train
and also with an healthy lifestyle you
can go in either direction right but
you're you're getting these shifts of
fiber types so somebody who does a lot
of endurance training for example in
their lifetime will when biopsied have
many more type ones whereas these a weak
kind of strength and power up athletes
have a ton of the two A's ya know I'll I
often hear people saying that they're
like oh I want to Train so I can get
more 2x you know because 2x is the
biggest and the most explosive it is
there any any reason that somebody
should set out to do that no so I mean
in fact that actually goes back to
comparing the homogeneous to the single
fiber because the homogenous only
quantifies 1 2 a and 2 X then it is sort
of inappropriately identifying what is
in fact to a 2 X hybrid as a peer 2 X so
when we analyzed the the fiber type
distribution in these world-class
Olympic real lifters there there were no
type 2 X in any of the athletes when we
did the single fiber analysis yeah I
mean I used to always tell people if you
want to get more 2x fibers just stop
moving entirely or go to space because I
mean that's really the the kind of the
fiber type at least from what I've been
taught that you get essentially from
extensive D training like when you
extensively D train we tend to see more
of those 2x but in someone who's
otherwise mobile and especially doing
any kind of training that they they
really don't seem to be very prevalent
do that yeah so really and again now
with being able to identify these
hybrids you're seeing the vast majority
of these to a 2x hybrid fibers in
sedentary people in disease populations
in overweight people where as you're
gonna get
more of the the to the pure to a in
somebody who is an athlete you know
particularly a strength of power athlete
but you really though the with a
development of this sort of ability to
identify those hybrids we don't see 2x
anymore but if you're the Sanitary
people that's right you're seeing a lot
of the the hybrids but going back to the
homogeneous again there is no ability to
see that and so then it's going to be
classified as 2x okay so you messin with
the the homogenate basically we go in we
take a muscle biopsy we grind it up and
then we kind of sort it out from there
so how does the single fiber technique
how does it differ from that so with the
single fiber you're actually separating
out with tweezers under a microscope
each individual fiber it's like teeny
tiny strands of hair it's very
time-consuming where we think with each
fiber that you were able to tease out
then you put that in a test tube and you
are only looking at the depth of the
fiber type itself of that single fiber
so essentially when it's reported in a
paper as 30 percent or 50 percent or
whatever it is then that's expressing
the frequency of that particular fiber
type in a given sample so let's say I
separate out a hundred fibers analyze
all of them how many of those were type
one then we're saying okay this this
occurs this often but the sort of
downside of that analysis is that you're
not able to identify that at the area
that it's taking up we're only able to
say oh this is this is type 1 type 1 2 a
etc whereas the homogeneous it's all
about quantifying area okay so I have a
quick question how so I get that the
single fiber analysis is my
better if you want to know kind of
granularly what each of your fibers
actually looks like but in terms of in
terms of like I guess being able to
guess or predict something about
performance I as I wonder does it
actually matter and I don't say like I
wonder as a I'm leading you to an answer
I say I wonder as and like I actually
wonder cuz I don't know too much about
this so basically like let's say someone
has 50% type ii fibers and looking at
the emotion the homogenate it's you know
like forty percent type to a myosin
heavy chains and ten percent type to x
versus when you do the single fiber
analysis you see it's like you know
thirty percent pure type to a and twenty
percent to a two x hybrids so like both
kind of work out to the same thing but
like does one or the other
tell you anything different about what
sort of performance you could expect
from that athlete or is it just that the
single fiber kind of gives you more
granular information if you want to do
like research on like fiber type shifts
or something like that yes and I think
especially just to bring up those
hybrids again when for example if you're
a sedentary person with a ton of those
to a 2x hybrids and then you start
training then those will shift to pure
to a and so that has some kind of
implications for overall health
potentially in terms of performance we
in our group of like I said these were
elite kind of best work weight lifters
that there are they had a ton of two A's
as you would expect for strength and
power athletes but when you compared on
the high individual level their
particular fiber type distribution to
performance it was not a predictor at
all I I gotcha so basically for for kind
of like health implications the just
percentage of hybrid fibers is kind of
an indicator that okay maybe this person
doesn't exercise much and if someone has
very few of them they probably exercise
more but but beyond that it's not that
that huge of a deal like am i
understanding that correctly yeah I
think it also it depends on the sport
okay go for it
it might be having more type two A's
might be more beneficial if you are
doing something like Olympic
weightlifting where you have to move a
lot of weight very quickly
so the idea that it's not necessarily
about how strong you are but more about
or you know say more speed than force
production necessarily that that might
help but if the idea that oh you
currently have 60% to a should you be
striving to get 65% like you you will
have more to a period just from doing
resistance training and so I don't think
it's a particularly good measure of
performance especially when you're
comparing one trained person to the
other it's worth pointing out in this
sample you had six world-class female
weight lifters and then in terms of like
national caliber it looks like nine
females and six males so you know we're
basically we're looking at how fiber
type related to performance but in a
sample that was already tremendously
well trained and competitive right
that's right and so you're it's
basically just saying okay well once we
get to this we were trying to see what
what makes you world-class right instead
of the national is there something that
we can see here that would is it about
the fiber type or is it just that your
training history is probably shifting
fibers in one direction or the other and
so it seems more like K these more
seasoned athletes who have been training
for longer have higher percentages not
oh the strongest competitors have the
most two A's that makes sense
so so when people talk about fiber type
shifts what what time frame are we
probably talking about here so like if
if someone you know if someone starts
with like 30% hybrid fibers at what
point so I guess two questions so like
one at what point like how long would
someone probably have to Train to get it
to where they pretty much have pure
fiber types with not that many hybrids
left in the mix a and then B at what
point does at what point has the fiber
type shift kind of run its course
assuming you train kind of the same way
over the course of a training career
like how how long does it take for that
for those adaptations to be fully
realized well there's not a huge amount
of work here but there is some in that
you actually can see these changes in
just a few weeks at least kind of
preliminary but the most dramatic change
would be if I take somebody who's a
marathon runner and he starts
powerlifting or Olympic lifting and and
vice versa right because you you have
that much more room to shift in terms of
of what happens when you keep training
like that it's we're getting dictated by
the training so assuming you have you
experienced the shift and then continue
to train in the new
then I'd say you you're likely to
maintain those adaptations but for most
people who end up going through kind of
phases of less training or switching up
what they do for exercise or just
getting a little bit more sedentary then
you would have the shift back
potentially or the ship to the hybrids I
got you that makes sense
another sort of interesting note with
that sample is there was this really
startling the high number of percentage
rather of those the two a2x hybrids in
the heavy weights and but not in the the
other weight classes interesting and
there's not a lot of research on kind of
obese but highly trained athletes
so yeah interesting what do you make of
that observation well I think it's it's
sort of it's in line with the we're
seeing these in more sedentary or in
more disease populations but then you
have to say well but then does it matter
for if you're also seeing them in these
I mean I'd say fairly healthy or at
least in terms of performance right yeah
because I mean looking at the numbers it
looks like the heavy weights accounted
for 91% of the to a 2x fibers that were
found within the whole sample that's an
even is a huge number and it's it's
really prop you know we could say that
it's not it's both training and kind of
body mass that is the predictor of of
these of the fiber type distribution but
I think what's more interesting is that
having all those hybrids doesn't appear
to affect their performance
I mean you've got a parcel of being that
heavy yeah I feel like the more I'm
involved in this conversation the more
I'm like man we need to start like
updating some text books you know what I
mean like I mean Greg already alluded to
this but just the the the things that
I've been taught and like I'm not a
dinosaur I
I finished I finished grad school like
five months ago it's not like I'm like
relying on you know some dusty old
textbook that's out of print like we
need to update this stuff because it
sounds like we're learning a lot about
fiber type and kind of improving the
methodology in the methodology quite
rapidly so it's kind of crazy that you
can talk to somebody and you know think
that you have a good handle on this
stuff and then realize like there's a
lot more to this than what's being kind
of currently taught even it even at high
levels sure and I mean it's evolved a
ton I mean at least you're not seeing to
be fibers anymore in but in most
textbooks but still um you know yeah
that's like the the source of confusion
that will never go away is like the to
be to X thing in terms of nomenclature
it will just always persist and always
be present and annoying so when an
athlete worries about their fiber type
like it if an athletes like losing sleep
over whether or not let's say they're an
endurance athlete and they're like I
hope I have a ton of type 1 fibers but I
just don't know or if they're an
explosive athlete and they're just like
praying that they have a bunch of you
know super fast twitch fibers do you
think it makes a lot of sense for people
to worry about that or like like doesn't
seem to really be in the big picture an
important determinant yeah well I think
what we don't know is how much is
dictated by what you're born with and
how much is dictated by training so we
really just need to biopsy a bunch of
newborns and then follow them throughout
their life and continue to biopsy them
good luck with that
we have sweet eye I'm all for that
I think it's it's silly to work to worry
about it because what are you gonna go
get a biopsy are you gonna get them
regularly are you gonna pay for somebody
to analyze your fiber type shifts like
you're much better off just focusing on
your performance I never know people are
doing DNA tests in the mail these days I
mean we could Papo
the lab and you know open up the doors
make some money that's true what one of
one of the so there aren't that many
papers looking at this but I remember I
remember back in the day reading some of
like poliquin's old stuff and the idea
that the way you could know whether you
were type one or type two dominant was
take eighty percent of your max do max
reps if you get substantially more than
eight reps you're probably type one
dominant if you get like four you're
probably type two dominant and like
eight was kind of the the bright line
where more than eight type one fewer
than eight type two and there then like
three or four papers published looking
at that with kind of like a rep max test
and then kind of looking to see whether
like percentage of type one fibers
predicts how well someone is going to do
on a on a rep max test like that and
they basically find that like yeah there
may be some sort of a relationship but
you're dealing with r-squared values of
like 0.1 or something like that so that
that kind of makes me think that very
much like you're saying like it's it's
not that fiber types are irrelevant but
I think I think it's it's definitely
possible to worry too much about them
and if the amount you're worrying about
them extends beyond like you know I'm
like a national level athlete and like
do the international people maybe have a
leg up on me that I can't have access to
like okay well maybe then it could
become relevant but for most of us like
it's it's not predictive enough to to
really lose sleep at night about unless
we could do like fiber transplant if we
can encounter with like a bunch more
type ii fibers i know in in in vitro
research you can you can induce like
complete fiber type shifts by
stimulating a motor nerve at a
particular frequency and like
high-frequency stimulation
we'll make all of the fibers downstream
a bit tight too and low frequency
stimulation will make all of the fibers
downstream type 1 it makes me wonder if
you could perhaps have a model with like
kind of high volume e stem over the
period of several weeks to induce like
very profound fiber type shifts within
individuals and see if that changes any
like functional characteristics but I
don't think anyone's actually seeing
whether that principle still applies in
vivo or not yeah I mean I think you're
looking at way bigger muscles so yeah
yeah even if that were to sort of micro
level but you could sell some gimmicky
product I think you're onto something
there that's the only kind of product we
sell Lauren you recently had a review
paper come out with Robert Morton and
stu phillips and you guys kind of laid
out it's called training for strength
and hypertrophy an evidence-based
approach and you guys kind of just
summarized the resistance training data
that that's available to date and kind
of put it into some practical takeaways
since you're a coach rather than having
you kind of rehash the whole paper the
paper kind of talks about frequency
intensity and volume guidelines now you
just ran a big study in a bunch of
resistance trained females looking at
different volume levels when you
basically get a new client and you're
starting from scratch you don't know a
ton about their training history you
basically have to set out the frequency
intensity and volume guidelines where do
you typically start with somebody that's
new I think when you're coaching someone
you need to tailor it way more to their
lifestyle their desires so it's if what
I thought was quote-unquote optimal but
it's not feasible to you then that's
it's kind of a silly recommendation
so I think really though the big take
home is that a lot of this can be
tweaked based on preference you know for
example if somebody wants to do really
high frequency training but then spread
out their volume over the week then I
think that's fine it's if someone wants
to go to the gym for longer three times
a week that's probably just as fine so I
know it's kind of a boring answer but I
think I'll put a lot in a lot of this
literature where we're looking at
optimizing this and that it kind of gets
lost of weight so does everyone want to
spend two hours in the gym does everyone
want to do twenty five sets of squats a
week yeah so every every client is
basically you start out with a blank
slate you basically start with the
basics like how many hours a week can I
get you to Train how many days is that
gonna be over and you just kind of
reverse-engineer it from there
sure I mean I generally the people I get
are already lifting I'm not working with
brand new people so I look at really
what are they doing now what are their
goals how are they recovering and we can
kind of tweak it from there but it's I
think it's it's just isn't a
one-size-fits-all thing a lot of people
are if that goes for volume that goes
for exercise selection I think there's a
lot of dogma in terms of oh you know
everyone must bench and everyone must
deadlift and it's like yeah they're good
exercises but not everybody has to do
them so looking at what what the person
likes and what's appropriate for their
goals I think is really I feel like I'm
not adequately answering your question
yeah no I mean I mean it kind of comes
back to like your your your impressions
of the study that you ran is like I
could you know give you a perfectly
conducted statistical test comparing
high volume versus moderate but what you
don't see there is that for some people
the high volume approach would have been
ideal
some of the moderate would have been
ideal and for a lot of people it
probably should have been somewhere
between you know so I think a lot of
people look to the resistance training
literature thinking that they're gonna
look at singular studies and aggregate
them and get kind of a blueprint
whatever reality it's more just kind of
showing you workable ranges or effective
zones that you can kind of operate
within it so important to point out that
this is just eight weeks and for the
most part there are you're all you're
just looking at a month two months three
months of training and so even if it was
great for those eight weeks or for those
12 weeks that doesn't mean you should
always train that way yeah I kept
telling bill that he should have
extended your project make it like a
year or two but he just wouldn't listen
mmm yeah no you uh do you have any like
certifications outside of your degrees I
do I haven't CSCS and from the NSC a and
I have a sports nutrition certification
from the ISSN and I think they might be
expired now but once upon a time I was a
Mazen trainer and ace group fitness and
kettlebells and tear ups and prenatal
all that right yeah I don't care about
any of that though you're certified with
not yours
were you just setting yourself up to say
that Eric no no I have a pertinent
question those are those are fine
organizations but not relevant to my
interest right now now you hold a
certification from the wine and spirits
Education Trust is that right I do what
is that
so that is the certifying body for small
use so you're a certified Somali yes I
am NOT I didn't go all the way you you
have to it takes years you have to do
many courses so I have the level three
and I'd have to do two more levels in
order to then take that test
oh it's level three like the lowest love
level one would be the lowest level but
thank you for that but you have to you
have to get up to what level six level 5
level 5 yeah so these are its courses
where you learn about wine and spirits
and you taste them and then you take a
test and is that the certification that
you're most proud of it is I highly
value my knowledge of wine and spirits
have you seen the movie sideways with
Paul Giamatti yes how how true to life
is that movie it's fairly true it but
it's if there's like levels of snobby
right so it is true that you can smell
and identify different types of grapes
and even different regions that's
actually when you take the test you need
to be able to identify the region and if
you're going to be a small you even need
to be able to identify their vintage
that's wild
yeah it's yeah so which one would you
pair with seaweed if you had to like
choose one so it Gregg a little inside
information there was a time where every
time I like checked in with Lauren to
see how she was doing she was currently
basically living off of seaweed and wine
it was like all she ate for like four
months so you say Selim eat seaweed yeah
are you still dizzy weed and wine diet I
I haven't had the seaweed in a while I
haven't even thought about the seaweed
they were good they were like these
seaweed seaweed thins is what they were
mmm yeah yeah just like chips made
purely it's just seaweed right it's just
seaweed with some other spices on them
yeah I know I had those before they're
they're delicious they are they're so
good but they were expensive and I had
to reprioritize make sure you're not
gonna get goiters though earlier this
year I was also on the gas-station diet
which was you know energy drinks
pretzels and
protein bars highly recommend that one
solace now you won the state Spelling
Bee in the fifth grade is that right I
did I can't believe you know all these
facts about me
well I do a lot of research I've got
connections what state was that in that
was New York State okay not not the
worst of states yes so that's like
that's like a legit state when that
showed up I was like well is she from
like Rhode Island or something but no
New York that's that's big-time Greg you
are just our Rhode Island audience just
disappeared with that absolute slap in
the face
did they ever appear in the first place
most of our listeners are from Rhode
Island it's you know huge but small
following I kind of think that Rhode
Island much like Finland doesn't
actually exist and is a vast conspiracy
dude you know I love Finland why would
you say that that's like my favorite
place are you aware of the Finland is
doesn't exist conspiracy because it's
it's a good one yeah I see about just
Google like reddit Finland doesn't exist
it's like it's like a whole thing I've
been there you think you think you have
you've been you've been to southern
Norway weird okay well I I have a lot of
work to do then I I need to get to the
bottom of that so Lauren this is a
question we ask a lot of people that
either do a lot of training themselves
or coach athletes is there anything in
your training or anything you have your
clients do that maybe goes against the
grain in terms of like what a lot of
evidence-based people do or like maybe
anything that there's just no evidence
to support it but you just like swear by
it hmm well I think people turn their
nose noses up at machines and machines
should be get you know get it been a
little bit more credit especially for
training for muscle growth what I see is
a lot of people kind of treating
strength goals and must
growth goals too similarly and you see
that with people who prescribed the
powerless to everybody regardless of
whether they are a power lifter and and
also just saying oh you have to do
barbell training or you have to do free
weight training so I think again based
on goals but I also personally like
doing more exercise variety than is
probably backed by evidence so like even
like week to week you're kind of
constantly cycling through different
variations yes so what I wonder is
assuming you're gonna get the most out
of let's say your first set maybe two
sets and then in you know it's kind of
diminishing value from there if you're
doing four sets or five starts then why
not do four different exercises for that
muscle group for just one to few sets I
I think that's a perfectly reasonable
question to ask and I mean if nothing
else it keeps training more exciting
like you you can you can kind of get
excited about doing an exercise but like
you're not still excited about doing
that exercise on your seven said you
know that's right and I mean I think
given a complicated exercise that that's
the requires more skill than probably
that doesn't make sense but if you're
doing different variations of curls or
different kinds of ISIL whatever tricep
exercises or III actually think that
should be in my mind at least that
actually could potentially be better
than just doing five sets of the same
kind of curl I really like that
I've been I've been so bored with my
training lately I'll just like you know
do a bunch of sets of one exercise and
move on and I get lost
my thoughts which is a horrible place to
be for me so I maybe I should start
switching up like that I like that idea
now you mention the machines what's your
what's your go-to machine that you like
so when I get I used to be somebody who
was super into following a structured
program and logging my progress and
everything and then I got busier and I
started doing research and so my
personal training is certainly
suboptimal but I'd say when you get
burnt out to just go into the gym and do
whatever you feel like doing is the best
way to get back into training as opposed
to trying to be optimal all the time but
like is there one machine that you just
get absolutely stoked to to get to I'm a
big fan of well collateral is that there
is a right answer for this but I want to
see what you say before I tell you there
is it there's a right answer I don't
know I don't know what you're gonna say
there's actually two right answers
there's the the Hammer Strength
horizontal leg press which is tremendous
they're not a sponsor of the show but
they should be there's also the Hammer
Strength pullover machine super vintage
you can't find them anymore it's like
they're nowhere anymore but they were so
legit but man Hammer Strength they just
don't make them like they used to Greg I
feel like the more the more commercial
gyms I go to the newer ones they just
don't load up on the Hammer Strength
stuff anymore and it's a shame because
that stuff was I mean if you bought a
Hammer Strength machine 80 years ago it
still works the way it did when you
bought it
those things are so solid and incredible
so the robotic machines but I would go
with a tibialis anterior machine oh
that's a good one yeah and also oh it's
it's the forearm like you roll it up
basically to work their forearms and
then you roll it the roll
wait up and then you roll it back down
what's your highest max on HIV Alice
anterior machine oh I have all my
clients to 1 RM tibialis anterior it's
perfect yeah all right well Lauren
thanks so much for your time I
appreciate you coming on if people want
to I mean like I said you're you kind of
just started getting into the research
world so people are going to be seeing a
lot more of your work moving forward and
if somebody wants to keep up with you
and your work that that will be
forthcoming how do they how do they stay
in touch and and stay up to date with
that well you can follow me on instagram
at Lauren cs1 but I only post six or so
times a year and generally I just use
Instagram to look at videos of
Frenchie's are you are you pandering
right now are you pandering no so did I
get you hooked on Frenchie Instagram the
best tight corner of Instagram it was a
it was just a mutual thing for the past
I don't know here yeah so Lauren has
Lauren understands that when she finds a
video of a hilarious Frenchie she's
supposed to send it to me so it's
probably a little bit of pandering but
okay so you're using Instagram mostly as
a Frenchie vessel for now that's right
but I will occasionally share some other
stuff like pictures of my own dog videos
of my own dog and then you know some
signs here and there
awesome so any other social media just
Instagram that is it I have a Facebook
that I never use can you tell how much I
love social media yeah it seems like
you've got a good strategy put together
well I will say this I feel like I don't
want to be regurgitating other people's
information and so until I have a unique
perspective to share on a topic
I don't see much value in me posting
about it yeah I mean you do kind of see
people who like very clearly take on
this idea like I'm gonna post something
every day from here on out and it's like
do you have a good thing to say each day
because if not that's probably not an
awesome strategy because now you've just
become noise on people's timelines you
know that's right and it's usually like
a selfie in a Sports Bra talking about
protein intake or just like we're just
like all of those memes where it's like
hey did you know that the like organic
version of Reese's Cups have the same
calories as the non-organic version this
is really contributing to society Thanks
well all of those drives me crazy cuz
it's like dude are you just assuming
people are too dumb to read a nutrition
label Gregg what did you send me or you
showed me the other day it was um wasn't
it like a really helpful image telling
people not to eat Nacho Cheese Doritos
[Laughter]
it was like it was like instead of
snacking on this snack on this there's
like [ __ ] Nacho Cheese Doritos and
like steamed broccoli or something like
come on man like no no no one is going
to think like man this is my [ __ ]
conundrum for today like I I'm trying to
stick to a diet and I want to snack on
something do I go with the [ __ ] Nacho
Cheese Doritos or do I go with the
broccoli man I wish someone on Instagram
would help give me clarity on this one
the other one I like that you see all
the time is like let's see you need 30
grams of protein should you eat a
delicious steak or a hundred and
thirteen pounds of broccoli and it's
like you know it's all the same look how
much more full and happy you'll be if
you instead eat seven bowls of broccoli
but the other thing that it was a huge
huge flaw with the one that you found
with the the Doritos is that the Cool
Ranch version is way better than nacho
cheese anyway which like if you're gonna
put out that information at least be
helpful
I agree plus your mouth doesn't get all
orange and your hands don't get all
orange yeah Lauren did you ever have the
the special edition Taco Bell flavored
Doritos I did not because I haven't
consumed Doritos as an adult but I saw
them used wait they still make them I
mean I spent them when they came out
yeah I'm thinking back to childhood it's
kind of like all I had going for me when
I was a little kid Greg did you ever get
the opportunity I never had any of the
Taco Bell like cross-promotion ones but
I did have many sweet and spicy chili
Doritos which that that is my dark horse
that is the best Dorito flavor man I've
never had that what a shame
we're too late to try and you put them
on your fingers and there it's like
pointy it's a cone
wait Oh what do they called like bugles
or something yeah yeah yeah those were
cool that was my dad's go to do you guys
remember how how gnarly the 90s were
when they had the Doritos 3d oh yeah
those are so good that in like the like
the clear like all of the the the coke
blue uh and then and then like the Green
Shrek ketchup like God the the night the
90s to early 2000s were just on another
level culinarily like I don't think
we'll ever get back to that level as a
as a culture no because it was basically
like let's make food really fun for kids
by making it as processed as humanly
possible hell yeah we had lower obesity
rates back then than we did now I'm just
saying bring back the dunkaroos like if
you do if you look at the correlation
between how much Shrek ketchup is being
sold and childhood obesity rates like
I'm just saying my evidence-based
conclusion is that we need to
reintroduce Shrek ketchup back onto the
market and that'll that'll get childhood
obesity back down to the levels there
they were at 15 years ago have you
identified the chemical
in Shrek ketchup that's carrying obesity
yeah it's whatever green dye they use
it's got to be like a lead-based green
dye that's the part that's so astounding
to me cuz like tomatoes are really
[ __ ] red man like you need you need
some sort of like very hardcore color to
not just change the color cuz like you
could you could put like something dark
in it and make it darker but to take
tomatoes which are incredibly red and
make them a very vibrant green color
like just the sheer level of chemistry
necessary to pull that off I personally
and I don't think I'm alone here I think
that's deserving of a Nobel Prize I
think that's probably as good a spot as
any to end an interview it's it's only
downhill from here
so Lauren a that I love Rhode Island and
I wasn't part of any of that really
negative offensive commentary I throw
out something really offensive at least
once per episode and it comes from a
place of love and also just let me say
full disclosure I grew up in the forest
and you're actually only the like eighth
woman I've ever talked to who I'm not
blood-related to so if I said anything
grossly misogynistic I apologize yeah I
mean I just wanna as the person that has
to edit all the podcasts like Greg
usually says at least one thing per
episode that I I'm just horrified by
sometimes they sneak through and usually
it'll be--it'll aggravate like you know
50% of the world population or like you
know 18% of the world population so if
we get through an episode and all we did
was lose Rhode Island we're technically
like pretty okay so no one's gonna blame
you for that and we're gonna survive
that pretty well well I'm a Canadian now
so yeah so we just gained an entire
country of extremely enthusiastic fans
we've tapped into the Canada base which
is big for us that's right
I don't we join your podcast as a
co-host so you can now tap into the
international market so actually Greg is
not a permanent co-host he's on kind of
a temporary situation so we might we'll
talk later
mmm sure anyway we're glad that you
called it all the way from Canada thanks
so much for spending some time with us
today and everyone that's listening make
sure you stay up-to-date with everything
Laurens doing on Instagram it should be
she's due for another dog post in about
two months and then some information
about four months after that so make
sure you keep an eye on that
all right Lauren thank you so much for
coming on have a great day thank you
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you